so viele schon da was ist denn hier los ich hab angeschaltet wir sind noch unter einer
minute 13 leute hat da und schon am rumspermen und zarex habe ich vorhin schon gesehen der war
schon im chat bevor der stream angekommen ist ja da heute heute gucken wir daher vorbei ihr kennt
mich kann durchaus sein dass wir es wieder nicht gebacken kriegen aber präge leute präge vielleicht
haut das hin ich hoffe den rest ich hoffe den rest also ich habe jetzt nichts im kopf wo ich mich
also noch noch kommt natürlich darauf an was ihr schreibt wo ich groß moment moment moment moment
moment moment moment teams hat wieder rum gesagt zack gachi bus na wobei es geht eigentlich
einer also wie gesagt ich habe nichts was ich wo ich jetzt im kopf schon hätte großartig
gesagt tracked zu werden aber man weiß ja nicht change size of text apps and other items ok
excellent wenn aus poggers gut dass du mir das vorgeschlagen hast das habe ich jetzt unbedingt
gebraucht nein gibt es es gibt keine also zwei sachen es gab keine aktuelle version vom
mainboard auf github nie es gab mal irgendwie so ein prototyp und eine aktuelle version gibt
es gar nicht die letzte version ist von 2018 oder so also ich verwende immer noch ich mein
guckt mal hier leute und also nur nur dass ihr dass ihr seht wie alt das zeug ist sieht man die
view version irgendwo vielleicht kann es kann man im source code irgendwie die verwendeten
view gs versionen sehen ja view 2.5 17 copyright 2014 bis 2018 also die software ist von 2018
2.5 2.5 17 nicht 2.6 17 ok wann kam view gs wann kam view gs 2.5 17 raus ich kann euch das
genau sagen alle kommen nicht einfach hier jetzt gibt es noch nicht mal eier kam raus
1 august 2018 was ist da los warum hat view gs bitteschön dies letzte kommet von vor zwei
wochen normalerweise ist das also früher wurde das mega krass bearbeitet kann das sein mal
mal so alle frage an die an die web developer gemeinde hier so dies da auch manchmal so
vereinzelte javascript fans gibt view gs hat die letzten also sagen wir so die letzten zwei
drei jahre schon ein bisschen an an schwung und und sagen wir so die letzten drei jahre vielleicht
sogar view gs hat die letzten drei jahre so ein bisschen an schwung und hype und und beliebtheit
verloren oder man liest auch kaum was drüber also wenn ich wenn ich von javascript frontends
aktuell was höre dann ist es welt das ist natürlich irgendwie an jeder ecke gerade zur
zeit wird da was drüber erzählt nach wie vor react das ist nicht nicht tot zu kriegen allerdings
soll gs auch so also es ist immer nach wie vor react es ist aber auch neue sachen so was
wie svelte natürlich soll gs dann habe ich gehört von astro hört man ab und zu auch mal
wobei das glaube ich jetzt auf da nicht so krass beliebt ist und so ein paar neue sachen aber
ehrlich gesagt wie du hat die letzten jahre letzten drei jahre ja angela hatte es auch zurecht
kass angela aber von view hört man erstaunlich wenig hier hängt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
damit zusammen ob man aktiv anwendung betreibt betreut entwickeln in view dann hört man natürlich
auch mehr ja dass das das gefühl habe ich auch wobei ja view 3 ich muss sagen ich habe nie eine
größere view 3 anwendung gemacht weil mich ein paar sachen weil man sich als abgeschreckter
dass es grundsätzlich anders aussieht wobei es das gar nicht muss das alte wird ja immer noch
supportet es hat ja schon die richtigen ansätze gehabt aber die haben es irgendwie ein bisschen
zu sehr zu sehr von jetzt auf gleich gemacht dass ich mal gucken mal gucken wie viele surfer wir
heute schaffen eine runde wir müssen noch mal ganz kurz mal wieder updaten weil wir verwenden
ja art spidey wey und beide wey art wisst ihr ja rolling release und rolling release muss
natürlich auch öfters mal abdehnen und es war ein kernel update dabei dass im endeffekt schon
mal heißt wir müssen den rechner neu starten riechburg beim riechburg genau ruby
leute ratet mal ein passwort ihr kommt nicht drauf super secret wer kommt auf ein passwort
123 456 korrekt 123 456 best practice passwort so viele leute haben das passwort
das kann nicht schlecht sein du hast recht eigentlich gar keine blöde idee ja du hast
recht und dann nennen wir das vielleicht sogar update oder so ja aber wobei ist auch gar nicht
so schlimm so wenn so wirklich so wirklich großartig oft einmal am tag ausgeführt gucken ist
doch eigentlich okay man könnte man könnte allerdings man könnte tatsächlich sagen mal
kennen jemand kennt jemand warum ist die musik auf einmal so laut what the fuck eben war die
nicht so laut okay keine ahnung was manchmal mit der musik los ist heute kein chat wie ist
das stimmt wo ist der chat doch doch da sollte eigentlich da sein der chat hat gebackt guck mal
leute doch doch ich dachte eigentlich der chat für eingeblendet gewesen jetzt geht er wieder
ja ach ja kennt jemand von euch eine also ich habe mir so ein wenn toy haben wir sogar haben
das nicht sogar im stream gemacht nee glaube ich ich habe mir so ein wenn toy usb stick gemacht
mit mit mit allen möglichen sachen drauf und einer datenpartition falls ich mal wirklich
irgendwo irgendwo booten muss kennt jemand ein gutes linux distributionen downloader tool also
da wo ich zum beispiel einfach einmal im monat ausführe und er update die ganzen isos auf meinem
usb stick fällt da irgendjemand was schlaues ein wie man das am besten machen könnte ja von
handen näher von hand ist doch doof ich will in den script haben dem ich sagen kann aktuell
aktuelles ubuntu aktuelles debian aktuell ist hier das das das das runterladen diese
verschiedenen distros ohne dass ich mir selbst die die download urls raussuchen muss und so was den
den update den distro champ den brauchen bald noch das hat keine mobile apps ich weiß plus
geil du hast mir schon einiges vorgeschlagen aber es passt immer nicht hat keine mobile apps und
ohne mobile apps bringt mir das nix das habe ich drauf ich habe schon netboot drauf ich habe
schon netboot drauf das brauche ich das ist ich will die isos direkt updaten da drauf
obsidian ist auch nicht für mich das beste weil du keine notifications auf deinem weil weil die
mobile app keine notifications kann es ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach man würde nicht
erwarten aber das ist mario 64 alter das sieht mega aus also für mario 64
aber 64 das mega nice aus
ne das das problem ist gar nicht das ist super das ist super easy einen script zu
bauen was verschiedene distributionen runterlädt und dann auf ja es ist es ist so genau das ist
das problem du musst das ja updaten du musst es ja updaten du musst gucken dass
deine distros aktuell sind du musst gucken dass die download links aktuell das ist das problem
so einen script zu bauen was jetzt ist runterlädt und auf den usb stick packt das ist jetzt ja kein
großer akt das sind das sind fünf zeilen bash und oben ein array mit den download urls das ist
das ist easy aber das zu pflegen ist ja das problem übrigens serious marks ich habe ich
habe von deinem projekt die ritmi gesehen ich glaube ich also von dem hier ich glaube ich
musste ich demnächst konsultieren als fife hat mod consultant für eine neue schicke ritmi für
den vier champ das will ich auch nicht ich will irgendwas haben was so funktioniert wie ich mir
das vorstelle und ich einfach benutzen kann so sieht es aus
ok reboot ist fertig so was leute wo sind wir stehen geblieben ich erzähle auch gleich noch
mal leute macht euch keine gedanken wenn ihr nicht dabei wart letzten stream ihr habt erstens nicht
viel verpasst und zweit ich erzähle euch gleich noch mal um was es um was es geht kannst du ein
video zu deinem arch machen eine konfig meine konfig habe ich mittlerweile veröffentlicht
hier wo bloß schweig er ich weiß genau was du gemacht hast du bist auf google gegangen und
hast linux distro downloader gesucht oder hast du das gefunden ich habe das auch schon alles
gefunden aber das sind meistens irgendwelche kleinen programme die teilweise nicht mehr
maintained werden kaum sterne haben keine ahnung nicht alle distros unterstützen
ich kenne das das habe ich ja auch drauf das habe ich auch drauf doch doch brauche ich man
will nicht immer alles runterladen um da booten zu können ich kenne das außerdem braucht man
internet access dafür dass das funktioniert und im zweifelsfall musst du dann dein mobile gut
haben opfern wenn du einen ad hoc hotspot machst doch doch ich will die isos auf usb stick haben
es ist ja explizit der sinn dahinter warum ich das haben will ich habe aber auch ein net boot habe
ich auch darauf dass ich zweifelsfall als aktuelles booten kann ist schon ist schon halbwegs aktuell
vielleicht vielleicht plötzlich das doch das habe ich aber auch schon gefunden das habe
ich das habe ich auch schon gefunden ja also meine config hier meine config ist hier hier
findest du meine config ich habe irgendwo auch noch die alten dort falls drinnen die die da
irgendwie drei jahre im repokum gegammelt sind aber das sind die das sind die aktuellen nicht
wundern dass die dateien dort heißen und nicht so wie sie am ende heißen sollen das liegt an dem
config manager den ich verwende das aber kein ding du kannst dir die auch ohne config manager
runterladen du nennst die dann einfach in dort bestätigung halt wie sie heißen müssen
ja es gibt ja keine mobile app dafür ach du meinst du meinst ich soll eine mobile app
programmieren ne ich will ich will mir doch sowas nicht aufhelfen mann für solche basic
tasks es will irgendwas was funktioniert bezahle auch was für aber ich finde einfach nix wo
kauft man am besten ein key für vmw ne kann ich dir nix empfehlen weil ich keinen key shop partnership
mehr habe bei irgend wem und die sich wahrscheinlich alle nix nehmen ja also hier findest du meine
configs keine links posten leute ich weiß dass man einfach keys findet aber keine links posten
muss ich euch timeout wenn er links postet ja so sieht es aus also hier ist hier ist alles drin
das meiste also hier habt ihr die die die die shell config wimmer see und was ich start von
x und hier liegt halt der ganze andere krempel drunter das ist der prompt weil ich jetzt schon
öfters die frage bekommen haben was ist das für einen prompt das ist gar kein fertiger prompt
das ist ein selbst gebastelter prompt den findet ihr hier also als prompt ist es zwar als prompt
wie nennt man das prompt manager oder wie heißt das also das was es endlich den prompt generiert
das ist starship aber die config für starship ist halt die hier das ist bisschen bisschen
customized nicht großartig dass es den prompt genommen den es auf der webseite gab bisschen
ein bisschen customized und vor allem den zweizeitigen prompt draus gemacht weil ich persönlich mag
zweizeitige prompts das liegt zum größten teil daran wenn man sowas hier hat soll ich dann hier
hinten tippen oder so und wenn ich das da guck mal jetzt hätte ich noch nicht mal einen platz was
zu tippen wenn ich hier drinne bin wenn ich wenn ich es geteilt habe also das natürlich das
natürlich doof deswegen muss das so sein deswegen habe ich auch zweizeitigen prompt gemacht und es
ist der default prompt das default preset prompt mit ein paar kleinen anpassungen zum beispiel auch
dass wenn man in git repo geht alles angezeigt bekommt zum beispiel wenn ich in dem repo jetzt
neue datei anlegt dann zeigt er mir auch ne aber das ist das ist kacke wenn du das so teilst
guck mal hier dann würdest du dann da tippen und so ne das ist mist zeigt er aber dass es
unbenutzte datei da drin gibt und hier hinten habe ich noch hinzugefügt für dotnet projekte
dass man sieht welches dotnet framework man installiert hat das dotnet framework darf man
nicht sagen dotnet versionen installiert man installiert hat und welches welche versionen
als target drin steht ist das telos ja das telos haben der wahre cray schreibt moin moin hey ich
wollte mal sagen dass ich mega sympathisch finde jetzt schon mal nice dass du den stream gefunden
hast dank dir habe ich mich an die it getraut was machst du denn also beruflich oder bastelst du
bastelst du bis hier rum wie hieß der andere shell emulator von dem letzt meinst du das
terminal wir haben eigentlich außer zsh nix verwendet am anfang hatten wir ein bisschen
bash weil ich zsh noch nicht installiert hatte meinst du set servers das wo du üben kannst das
wo wir heute weitermachen das hier oder was meinst du das ist richtig du meinst das terminal oder
meinst du das hier das hier meinst du das hier wenn du einen terminal emulator meinst dann ja
das hier das ist westerm das ist das ist das ist immer noch das gleiche wie das was verletzten
es gesagt westerm ist das hier wetz wetz term also lasst ihn ruhig ein paar sterne da der hat es
auf jeden fall verdient es ist der beste terminal emulator ich die letzten jahre über gefunden
ab ja stimmt wo ist er eigentlich ach da ist er da ist er doch ja ja heute wenigstens senf nicht
wieder irgendwie komische komische sachen gestern war gestern war gestern nicht cola versus fand
da ne was war gestern irgendwas anderes war nicht senf das wird mich auch mal interessieren du
könntest ja mit gutem beispiel vorangehen erst mal erzählen was dein lieblings senf ist ich gebe
ja oft genug mein senf da dabei paints jam joke ich weiß
ja striker hat westerm programmiert das ist secret secret progress open source contributor
ja also für alle die nicht dabei waren im letzten stream ich versuche euch noch mal
kurz zu erklären was wir versuchen heute zu machen und zwar weil ich wollte gerade noch mal gucken
hier beruflich vor zwei jahren meines ist thema ausbildung begonnen da aber die systeme
integration von aktuell betrieb nicht gefallen hat bin ich zur anwendungsentwicklung gewechselt
mein betrieb ja das kann man ja kann man ja machen wie wichtig wichtig ist halt dass du vielleicht
schon in der ausbildung feststellts was der bereich ist der dir gefällt und da ordentlich
know-how aufbau dann ist die chance auch viel größer dass du später dort in dem bereich
arbeiten kannst also ich versuche euch noch mal kurz zu erklären was wir machen es gibt
eine seite die nennt sich set servers.com also die sind traurig sind weiß ich gar nicht haben wir
eigentlich den ja wir haben was in der richtung ja es ist das einzige dena pepo set sind die extrem
setge so und warum sind die set warum sind die server traurig weil die haben alle ein problem
es gibt 18 verschiedene übung und jede dieser übung gibt einem einen linux server bei aws
also bei amazon und die sind halt auf ihre art und weise kaputt und ziel ist ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach anhand des ersten beispiels noch mal das geht nämlich immer super schnell das erste
beispiel da gibt es nicht viel zu erzählen ach moment vorher muss ich erst mal wieder leute
nicht vergessen so das muss sein gucken wir mal yo sonst sieht man nämlich die uhr die leute
können sich auf mein system einloggen dann da ja also du kriegst eine aufgabe gestellt zum
beispiel dass wir den server haben auf dem festgestellt wurde festgestellt wurde dass
das log file voll läuft wir sollen jetzt feststellen was schreibt dann das log file
voll und den prozess beenden ne unten ist nix guck unten ist nix das ist nix nix schlimmes
das ist das ist die aufgabe können wir können wir tatsächlich machen wir können den schon mal
auf 15 minuten stellen also das ist das ist relativ easy das ist jetzt die aller allererste
aufgabe da macht man nix verkehrt ip leak fack aller jetzt vorbei private private ip leak so also
die aufgabe ist im prinzip ganz einfach damit damit der chat sich freut passt sich das immer
noch hier bei diebel also ein entwickler ein testprogramm erstellt das kontinuierlich in
die log datei war lock bed lock schreibt und die festplatte füllt sie können dies zum beispiel mit
blablabla überprüfen machen wir mal auf dieses programm wird nicht mehr benötigt finden sie
es und beenden sie es also das ist eine total simple aufgabe für jeden der ein bisschen die
logs erfahrung hat das ist aber auch die allererste aufgabe und auch als leicht eingestuft so ich
zeige euch jetzt mal wie man das zum beispiel machen könnte wir machen erst mal den t-max auf
starten hier oben quasi dass das jetzt immer monitoring sehen wir ok da schreibt was in
den datei und dann gucken wir einfach ls lsof und es geht um die datei war lock bed lock gucke
ich einfach wer welcher prozess hat file handles drauf stelle fest aha guck mal da bed lock punkt
bei prozess it 626 also sage ich kill 626 beim ihr seht in den log datei mit nichts mehr reingeschrieben
jetzt warte ich sechs sekunden und dann kann ich hier unten überprüfen lassen ob meine lösung
tatsächlich das ist wie ich es lösen sollte so check solution solutions korrekt so und dann
gehe ich hin sag sudo power off dass es ihnen ein bisschen weniger geld kostet und das war es
so funktioniert das und wir haben alles scenarios durch bis inklusive diesem hier glaube ich wo
sind wir gestern stehen geblieben haben wir haben wir dns schon gemacht ich glaube nicht ich kann
mich nämlich überhaupt nicht mehr daran erinnern dass wir irgendwas mit dns gemacht haben ich glaube
wir sind bei elf stehen geblieben also haben alle aufgaben durch bis elf das heißt heute
kommen die schweren aufgaben das haben wir auch gemacht das haben wir auch gemacht etcd da kann
ich mich doch noch dran erinnern wir haben etcd gemacht das war das wo der typ uns mit
einer ip tables regel geblieben hat port port 80 80 wird umgeleitet auf auf irgendwas anderes
oder so das haben wir relativ sicher haben wir das gestern gemacht es geht heute es geht heute
aber hart weiter und man muss ehrlich sagen also die ersten sachen sind wirklich easy also jeder
der ein bisschen sich mit linux beschäftigt hat und so seine linux admin def ops und linux skills
im allgemeinen üben will kann sich ohne probleme an eins bis drei ran trauen also das ist wirklich
nicht schwierig beim ersten geht es darum prozess abzuschießen beim zweiten geht es darum lock
kleine lock auswertung zu machen welche welche ip am meisten zugriffe verursacht hat das dritte
war irgendwelche dateien durch greppen und so das war wirklich nicht schwierig also ich weiß im
chat hieß es schon wieder alter ich wäre lost gewesen bei beider beim zweiten schritt aber
deswegen machen wir es ja auch zusammen also da könnt ihr euch also wirklich wenn ihr ein bisschen
traut euch jemand ran selbst wenn ihr es nicht in 15 minuten schafft ist ja kein problem die
zeitangabe hier ist übrigens nicht so nicht so wild also ihr könnt ohne probleme wenn die zeit
abgelaufen ist noch mal neu anfangen das einzige was passiert ist wenn die zeit abgelaufen ist dann
wird das server beendet also die aws vm wird runtergefahren was ja auch dazu da ist um kosten
zu sparen ich habe heute morgen übrigens mal versucht hier was zu aufzunehmen und ich muss sagen
aufnehmen macht das gar keinen bock live im stream ist das irgendwie viel cooler vor allem
haben wir die auch schon gemacht ich habe versucht mal ein bisschen was aufzunehmen und zu zeigen hier
leute wir machen bisschen bisschen linux zeug zeige ich euch ich zeige euch ein bisschen linux irgendwie
aufnehmen für den video hat hat sich irgendwie nicht der chat wieder kaputt ne chat sagt einfach
nix das war nix ich hoffe ich habe heute morgen nicht irgendwie hier zu viele angeklickt dass
ich jetzt gebannt bin oder so ja so sieht es aus da machen wir jetzt weiter genau ssl das ist das
mit mit dem ip tables jebait wo ein ip wo ein ip tables eintrag drinne war der gesagt hat wir
redirecten jetzt den den etcd port auf was anderes das war richtig hyper mega jebait leute das habe
ich auch erst gar nicht gefunden doch mache ich manchmal ja ich müsste halt meinem katter sagen
schneit das mal zusammen und ich bin mir immer noch unschlüssig ob so ohne meinen kontext dabei
das auf youtube so gut ankommt weil hier im stream sind ja zum kürzten teil leute die sich
für das thema interessieren wo ich dann auch mal ein bisschen was komplizierteres erzählen
kann und selbst wenn die leute nicht genau folgen können die können das so grob einordnen auf
youtube ist halt so die meisten auf youtube haben ja von der ganzen geschichte gar keine ahnung und
wenn man dann einfach nur die stream mitschnitte zeigt ohne dass ich was drumherum großartig
erklär die die steigen da wahrscheinlich komplett aus das heißt eigentlich müsste ich noch mal
neu aufnehmen und ordentlich dabei erklären was passiert und was was man da eigentlich macht
ist alles doof dass dass ich halt noch mal neu aufnehmen muss und noch mal neu aufnehmen ist
natürlich nicht so spontan und und irgendwie unterhaltsam wie wenn man das im stream macht
ist schwierig also mal gucken vielleicht vielleicht finde ich ja noch mal irgendwie so
die passende stimmung dafür das nochmal neu aufzunehmen ja bei youtube weiß man nie so
genau ok also gucken wir uns das ganze mal an wir sind stehen geblieben bei ssl trouble das
haben wir durch ok also wir fangen jetzt an mit einem schweren problem und zwar it's always dns
mal gucken was da auf uns zukommt bevor man übrigens den timer startet wir können den
timer mal kurz auf uns auf 20 20 minuten setzen 20 minuten timer gesetzt können wir uns bevor
wir das starten können wir uns mal die beschreibung angucken und zwar müssen wir müssen hier mal
5 5 hattige ai benutzen also was ist denn die beschreibung das server kann google.de nicht
pingen es wird ping zurückgegeben google.com name oder dienst nicht bekannt ok das müsste das
ding eigentlich nicht übersetzen erwartet wird dass der hausname aufgelöst werden kann hinweis
derzeit können die vms nicht nach außen pingen daran gibt es keine automatische überprüfung der
lösung test ping google.com sollte etwas wie ping google.com zurück ok also ping geht nicht
und wir sollen rausfinden warum nicht also es könnte routing sein was kaputt in wobei wenn
es eh nicht nach außen pingen kann ja gucken wir mal es könnte routing sein es könnte es könnte
eigentlich es könnte eigentlich alles alles mögliche sein warum das warum das nicht geht
gut dann legen wir das mal an und gucken was wir rausfinden können
pogu time auf geht's it's always dns wir starten die zeit sobald die vm fertig gebaut ist
ok auf geht's timer gestartet open terminal also dns ist kaputt probieren wir mal aus ob
das stimmt was er sagt ping google.com hätte ich jetzt auch nicht mit gerechnet dass es
jetzt geht aber man weiß ja nie also probieren mal als nächstes ns lookup nicht dick ist es
drauf jepp jepp dick google.com das funktioniert das ist schon mal sehr merkwürdig dass dns
auf lösung mit dick funktioniert allerdings bei ping nicht das ist komisch kannst du bisschen
mehr erklären was du machst ich habe noch nicht wirklich viel gemacht ok ich versuche das mal
ich muss allerdings irgendwie den ich muss irgendwie die aufgabe in der zwischenzeit auch
moment das ist das ist extrem sass das ist extrem sass dass man localhost nicht pingen kann
das stimmt was nicht das ist extrem komisch also ok ich versuche mal ich versuche mal grob zu
erklären was ich gemacht habe ich habe ssh session auf die kiste offen und die aufgabenstellung sagt
er ganz klar irgendwas geht mit namensauflösung nicht immer soll rauskriegen warum oder woran das
wo kann das wo kann das alias auf ping das ist eine gute gute sache ist es nicht oder wobei mal
gucken ob das wirklich hallo gestern konnte ich hier noch mittlere maus jetzt nicht mehr was
ist das gestern ohne scheiß gestern konnte ich mittlere maus taste hier drücken jetzt geht
das nicht jetzt muss ich so machen binary ok ne das ist das ist also ping ping ist auch nicht
irgendwie ne ne das ok ist überschrieben also leute ich kann sagen ihr dürft backseiten aber
ich werde mich nicht so sehr an euch orientieren weil es geht ja letztendlich darum dass ich
rausfinde wie das ist und nicht irgendwie 50 verschiedene sachen im chat gespammt werden was
es sein könnte und eines davon ist es dann aber backseiten zu viel ihr wollt immer auf die
gefahr hin wenn ich mir gar so sehr auf den keks geht dann teile ich euch aber es war die
letzten tage auch überhaupt kein problem ich sag so ihr könnt so viel backseiten wie ihr lustig
seid also was was mache ich habe mich auf der kiste eingeloggt und das erste was ich geguckt
habe ist ob ping wirklich nicht funktionieren ob ping google.de und ping google.de wirklich
nicht funktioniert wie hier angegeben weil wer kennt das nicht irgendeiner sagt x y z geht nicht
ihr probiert es aus und es geht vielleicht hätte es ja auch komplett gebadet sein können so das
ne was ist da unten eigentlich okay und dann habe ich geschaut okay ping ping geht nicht
aber ich habe danach direkt ein dns server gefragt also den default dns server gefragt mit dick dick
ist ein programm was genau für sowas da ist jepp jepp dick ein dns lookup utility sowas wie ns
lookup im endeffekt sowas ähnliches und das funktioniert das heißt im prinzip kann das
ding namen auflösen aber ping kann namen nicht auflösen was schon sehr merkwürdig ist und wisst
ihr was auch sehr merkwürdig ist dass localhost nicht funktioniert jetzt müssen wir mal gucken ob
dick localhost funktioniert das funktioniert okay also daran erkennen wir die dns auflösung an sich
ist vollkommen in ordnung aus irgendwelchen gründen funktioniert aber ping nicht gucken
wir mal ob das wirklich nur ping ist okay nee es ist karl ist es auch also sprich die namensauflösung
geht nicht aber wenn man die namensauflösung direkt ausprobiert dann geht sie was sehr sehr also
dass also dass man keinen ping localhost machen kann das ist extrem sass so als nächstes gucken
wir uns mal an hier der meckert ja auch schon rum dass er sich selbst nicht auflösen kann als
nächstes was wir machen ist wir gucken mal in etc host rein was da so drin steht wir stellen
schon mal fest localhost steht da gar nicht drin ich meine das muss nicht zwangsläufig drin
stehen glaube ich je nachdem was für ein lokales dns zeug verwendet wird aber das ist schon mal
merkwürdig das ist normalerweise die fault wir müssen jetzt mal gucken welcher server eingetragen
ist was der was der überhaupt verwendet für die namensauflösung und zwar ns lookup und zwar
der server okay da verwenden lokalen wahrscheinlich verwenden das system d resolve d oder so was in
der richtung gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus weil was anderes es könnte es könnte auch
wie heißt dieses andere ding lokal namen namen cashing ding n ns nsd oder irgendwie so was habe
ich vergessen ok da steht nix drin guck mal etc etc resolve konf was steht denn da drin dns
server ja gut lokal host es ist wahrscheinlich wirklich system oder resolve d wobei das eigentlich
wurscht ist was es ist die namensauflösung funktioniert ja ok die namensauflösung an
sich geht aber ping funktioniert nicht sehr krumm s trace s trace ping wenn einem sonst
nix mehr einfelder mit gs traced ok auf geht's excel excel alles klar ok karl vonst auch nicht
nee nee nee funktioniert auch nicht was jetzt haben wir das nicht peipen muss ich das jetzt
irgendwie redirecten oder kann man das nicht peipen man ist s trace standard standard error
oder oder wie das keckel punkt lock auch mal so ok anscheinend also was haben wir denn da drin
ping und ein bisschen größer machen ok ping das ist alles egal was macht das denn wie
fangen wir von unten an fangen wir von unten an ok google name of service not found resolve
konf guckt da rein resolve konf guckt da rein etc house guckt da rein ok wir probieren ihr
probieren jetzt mal was aus wir können es mal tatsächlich ausprobieren mit ping-6 wir
probieren jetzt mal was aus nee geht auch nicht wir probieren mal was aus und zwar
etc host etc host ich mein das wird nicht der weiß hat selbst das schluss dann ich
will einfach mal gucken ob es dann funktioniert weil das muss funktionen also wenn host datei
nicht funktioniert dann ist irgendwas noch noch grundsätzlicher kaputt google.com ok
das funktioniert easy gelöst ach nee geht nicht ok das ist auf jeden fall nicht gelöst
google in google in die host datei eintragen das kann ich wirklich die löse die lösung
des problem sein ok das funktioniert dann wird das wahrscheinlich wirklich was sein
in der reihenfolge wie die namensauflösung passiert
was anderes als google nee es geht nicht mal localhost nicht mal localhost funktioniert
etc host ok das das klappt also dann schmeißen wir schmeißen wir das mal wieder raus mein
das kann es jetzt ja nicht gewesen sein so also der guckt der guckt in resolve konf
rein um festzustellen welche dns server wobei ich gar nicht bin wir gar nicht so sicher
dann geht er nach etcs ok jetzt ist klar jetzt ist klar was passiert der fragt der macht nichts
der fragt überhaupt keine dns server ab andreas ich habe deine sache gesehen ich glaube das
das ist da ist was dran aber muss ich erstmal überlegen wie kommt man da drauf also das
ist jetzt natürlich schon mal interessant dass man sieht an der stelle der fängt an
etc resolve konf etc host aber der macht überhaupt keine dns anfragen das ist merkwürdig
obwohl er doch eigentlich namensauflösung machen sollte nee iptables ist es nicht man
sieht überhaupt keine abfragen deswegen machen wir jetzt mal das was der andreas vorgeschlagen
hat wir gucken in die ns switch rein das ist eine konfig datei die man eigentlich in 99,9
prozent der fälle weder öffnet noch editiert dns servers eingetragen ist das achso aber
das geguckt glaube das haben wir gar nicht überprüft ob der dns server eingetragen ist
das können wir dann gucken aber normalerweise fasst man diese datei hier gar nicht an sag
ich jetzt mal bevor ich da bevor ich da reingucke die macht man nicht auf da trägt man normalerweise
nichts ein da drinne ist definiert in welcher reinfolge die die linux c library funktionen
für die namensauflösung sich verhalten sollen also sprich in welcher reinfolge die verschiedene
auflösungs also verschiedene namenauflösungs sachen durchprobieren soll also host dns server
und solche geschichten da gucken wir jetzt mal rein und da sehen wir ok das soll haus
feils ich habe keine ahnung wie der richtige wie die richtige sonntags von der ns switch
punkt konf ist wenn ich ehrlich bin wobei ich sagen muss feils erscheint mir hier vielleicht
ein bisschen wenig ich weiß aber auch nicht was richtig sein soll wenn ich ehrlich ehrlich
sein bin ns switch punkt konf example ns switch punkt konf ja komm haben wir ein ordentliches
example ok was steht da sonst so drinne zum beispiel host dns das steht da nicht drinne
host dns ns lookup habe auch gemacht passt alles geht easy das wars das wars wohl da
muss man aber auch erstmal drauf kommen also ernsthaft das ist sehr abwegig also normalerweise
macht man da nix drinne ja vielleicht vielleicht für ad login und solche geschichten ja das
wars dann aber auch also ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich habe die datei in 15 jahren linux
administration keine ahnung zwei mal angefasst oder so die meisten leute wissen wahrscheinlich
von der existenz dieser datei also normalerweise musst du da nicht rein und musst du da auch
nix machen wir können mal kurz zum vergleich gucken wie das bei mir in der vm aussieht
mal es etc ns switch punkt konf so sieht es bei mir in der vm aus haus mein machine was
der fuck resolve unavailable return feils mein haus dns obviously alles klar ja keine ahnung
was uns das alles sagen soll aber das war in dem fall tatsächlich das problem in der
switch konf war falsch easy gelöst next sudo power off tag boom weiter gehts aber gelöst
more scenarios wir sind stehen geblieben bei it's always dns gut aber ja gelöst chat
ah sekunde sekunde sekunde ich bin ja auch doof ich muss es noch mal kurz aufmachen
habe ich es noch die warum habe ich das nicht mehr also ist noch da wir wollen uns mal die
lasst uns mal die offizielle lösung angucken ok also müssen wir nochmal klicken edit hier
da steht guck mal edit etc ns switch konf and add dns to the host line after files das
war übrigens after files ich habe es vor files geschrieben oder leute habe ich vor
oder nach files geschrieben ich glaube ich habe es davor geschrieben ist ist aber letztendlich
auch egal weil es funktioniert ja trotzdem dafür würden die sachen im haus in der haus
nicht mal funktionieren man könnte man könnte das wahrscheinlich sogar verbessern man könnte
dieses beispiel sogar verbessern indem man noch ein fehler einbaut wenn man es davor
schreibt anstatt danach ok nice wo sind wir stehen geblieben wo sind wir stehen geblieben
docker webcontainer can't connect to db container oh jetzt kommt docker stels man habe ich habe
ich bock auf docker stels leute wollen wir docker stels machen oder 14 wollen wir switching
oder ich lasse euch einfach aussuchen chat wir machen das jetzt anders wir machen das
anders ihr dürft euch aussuchen außer das sage ich euch gleich wir machen kein kooper
net das webapp ist not working da habe ich jetzt wirklich kein bock drauf ihr dürft
euch aussuchen das wir machen mal eine abstimmung wir machen eine abstimmung zwischen motge wir
haben zur auswahl ob wir bär machen wollen oder ob wir 13 13 13 14 16 17 oder 18 kam
man überhaupt so viele sachen eintragen welche welche welche von den aufgaben soll man machen
ist ziemlich ziemlich nee ist gar nicht so
knapp gar nicht so knapp ok es wird wahrscheinlich einfach 13 ja es wird 13 57 prozent sagen
13 erst 13 dann 18 nee ich frage euch danach magst du kannst du kannst die umfragen schon
bereithalten danach gibt es neue umfrage mal gucken vielleicht haben sich die leute danach
hier anders überlegt müssen bisschen müssen bisschen die impressions hochtreiben das zählt
bestimmt bei twitch genauso wie bei youtube wenn die leute interakt mit dem stream dann
ist das gut interactions farmen ok also wo sind wir hier 13 was ist denn das problem
ok ich habe da was von wordpress gesehen monka w ok also das ist das ist die aufgabe
ist aber nicht deutsch ich glaube ich glaube deep l ist verbackt
dann habe ich meinen freikontingent aus aus ausgeschöpft hat er probleme wegen dem html
oder ist der text zu lang hat der ok aus irgendwelchen gründen funktioniert jetzt ich weiß nicht
warum die bell hatte keinen bock also was haben wir denn da schönes es laufen zwei
docker container eine web anwendung wordpress was sonst muss ja muss ja nah an der realität
gehalten werden wordpress und eine datenbank maria db als backend und wenn wir uns die
webseite ansehen sehen wir dass sie nicht mit der datenbank verbinden kann ok komische
übersetzung aber wir wissen glaube ich was gemeint ist der ein der wordpress container
kommt nicht auf den datenbank container genau so karl gibt zurück ok kopieren wir uns das
ganze mal dies ist kein wordpress problem sie müssen wissen dass wp die umgebungsvariablen
wordpress db verwendet um die mysql verbindungszeichenfolge zu erstellen alles klar siehe zum beispiel
die wp konfigure und sonst datei html wp konfig punkt pap test sudo docker exec bla blub
dings ping ok na da gucken wir mal starten wir das ganze doch mal docker container can
connect to db container run 20 minuten haben wir gell 20 minuten 20 minuten zeit dann starten
wir mal den timer gleich sobald die vm erstellt ist wer sich übrigens wundert warum das hier
umso bundig ist das ist dass man nicht die adressleiste sieht weil die haben es nicht
für nötig behalten dass irgendwie an ip oder session oder sonst was zu binden jeder mit
der die id kennt kann sich remote auf die vm verbinden was nicht so nicht so five hat
ist ok auf geht's auf geht's erst mal ruht werden prinzipiell immer ruht werden docker
ps gucken wir mal was da läuft wir sehen das docker schon mal komplett hängt das nee
ok jetzt jetzt nicht mehr wir machen die restlichen setserver challenges oder tests so wir haben
einmal ein wordpress container einmal ein maria db container wir könnten jetzt natürlich
cheaten und uns das container image bei mir auf die vm runterziehen und mal ein bisschen
reingucken und so was aber wir cheaten mal nicht so also was was passiert wenn man karl
ausführt karl lokal host also das kann man sich hier schon mal sparen mit dem 80 hinten
dran und das können wir auch weg machen so could not resolve
lokal host nicht lokal host error establishing a database connection ok also wordpress ist
stimmt was da steht wordpress kommt nicht zum datenbank container ok ich würde sagen das
erste was wir machen ist docker exec minus it maria db weil zu laufen scheint daher wir
gucken wir gucken trotzdem mal rein bash so jetzt sind wir in diesem maria db container
und können jetzt da mal ein bisschen rumgucken der erzählt hier irgendwas von environment
variabel wir gucken uns einfach mal die environment variabel an also was sehen wir da mysql root
password ist password highly secure best practice password kann ich jedem nur empfehlen immer
oder oder alternativ 123456 123456 ist auch gut mysql database wordpress ok alles gut
ja in ordnung also das sieht eigentlich so weit schon mal ok aus jetzt gucken wir mal
folgendes wir gehen auf den wordpress container wordpress und gucken mal ob das auch wirklich
nicht stimmt ping command not found seriously ok karl ist wenigstens drauf alles gut irgendwas
irgendwas ping not found man was ist denn mit denen los ok karl wie ist der container
maria db maria db ok das ist schon mal ein problem der container kann den host nämlich
auflösen das heißt wir gucken jetzt mal wie die netzwerk konfiguration von docker container
ist wir sagen es einmal docker network ls ist es glaube ich ok es gibt ok es gibt nur
bridge host und dann das sind die default die default netzwerk settings das heißt als
nächstes gucken wir mal docker ins spec und ich glaube man kann direkt hinten dran den
krempel schreiben kann man docker kann man docker ins spec bridge machen oder so sieht
man da was da dran welcher da ja guck mal hier ok die hängen alle an der default docker
bridge da muss man sich nicht wundern dass es nicht funktioniert weil die default docker
bridge hat keine namensauflösung zwischen den containers nur custom bridges und custom
networks haben namensauflösung ich gehe davon aus ich weiß nicht genau warum die
das gemacht haben aber ich persönlich gehe davon aus um die dns konfig vom host nicht
durcheinander zu bringen ok das ist das ist das ist ein problem warum wordpress maria
db nicht auflösen kann guck mal hier haben wir auch hier haben wir auch die ip adresse
von von dem maria db container weil schlichter greifen die namensauflösung nicht funktioniert
wo wir wieder dabei sind dass das alles dns probleme sind wie in dem beispiel vorher sondern
testen wir jetzt mal ob wir denn theoretisch überhaupt so dahin kommen ok part 80 ist
refused auf welchem port läuft maria db muss ich das echt noch mal raus docker psa 336
ok pearl 3306 ok da läuft was da ist zwar not allowed aber da läuft was ok der container
kommt prinzipiell hin zum glück oder ich hoffe keine bescheuerten ip tables regeln
wieder drinnen die uns den spa... wobei leute ich trau dem typ nicht mehr der hat uns schon
so oft gebadet mit ip tables mist ok das war ein bisschen viel auf einmal
seh ich jetzt was denn das ach ne das ist docker default ok noch mehr ip tables ok ich glaube
ich glaube das ist ok ich glaube die ip tables dinger sind in ordnung ok aus ok mysql haben
die... ah guck mal der hat nen mysql client drauf pogu das ist cool minus how... wait
mal kurz gucken na natürlich nicht natürlich nicht ja was doch sonst minus minus help hast
du keinen compose fall nicht sprosch können wir mal gucken aber es sieht nicht so aus
als kommt es aus compose what the fuck meine güte da ist ja nix drauf auf dem container
man kann hier jemand nach oben scrollen was ist es minus minus was ist verbinden zum server
minus h minus kleiner connect to house nicht minus groß h kann ich mit der maus ja ich
guck mir gerade das hier an ich wollt gucken was die option ist für mysql um mich zu ner
datenbank zu verbinden so also mysql host das da access denied for user root using password
no und wie gibt man user an für so groß u vielleicht root oder klein u root was weiß
ich denn man ach da steht ja sogar ein beispiel null ok minus u nee das ist mysql admin aber
das kommt da minus u root minus p passwords ah geht doch ok also die verbindung die verbindung
ist prinzipiell richtig was nach p kommt ist das password ja aber anscheinend nimmt er
das leerzeichen mit oder so keine ahnung weil mit mit leerzeichen was sehr merkwürdig
ist für eine option keine ahnung was die da komisches getrieben haben sollte normalerweise
nicht so sein aber gut das ist das ist im prinzip alles richtig das heißt wir gucken
jetzt mal hier in die environment variablen was da drinne steht weil ich meine die haben
extra was von environment variablen hier erzählt wordpress db password password das ist richtig
wordpress db user root ist auch richtig jetzt ist nur die große preisfrage wo ist wordpress
db host oder sowas in der richtung nf crep minus i wordpress nicht oder wp nee word wordpress
die hostname das ist der ok wordpress db password wordpress db hausname ok wir müssen den hausnamen
setzen gehe ich mal von aus wordpress db host so geht das how to set wordpress db host ok
hier drinnen zu setzen bringt schon mal nix wir müssen den container editieren wir gucken
uns mal an docker inspekt wordpress und wir schauen uns mal an was da gesetzt ist also
das ist jetzt die config für diesen container was was beim erstellen alles angegeben wurde
also da wurde angegeben ok das ist jetzt alles relativ uninteressant network können wir
mal gucken das steht immer relativ weit unten bridge ip alles gut in environment müssen
wir mal gucken environment wordpress db wordpress db user und der rest sind irgendwelche irgendwelcher
pap shit ok also das weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht das geht irgendwie ich glaube mit docker
update oder sowas docker update change environment variable how to set environment blödsinn
die pepega ist auf stackoverflow wieder man docker update hier was weiß ich ja wieder
die richtige synthax ist ok update es gibt kein compose file guck gibt kein compose file
der hat die container einfach so gestartet hier change predefined environment variables
das brauchen wir ich stelle doch kein eigenes compose file was bringt mir das denn ich hab
noch nicht bei internet zugang weil das in dem fall wahrscheinlich schon gecashed ist
aber apple geht doch irgendwie hier nf ad docker update ok wie funktioniert das docker
update environment alter nf geht das nett muss doch das muss doch gehen man man kann
auch von man kann auch von bestehenden containers das environment update examples das war ich
weiß dass das funktioniert ich will mir sogar ein leichtes schon gemacht haben ich weiß
bloß nicht ob es docker update war das ist mein problem ok docker change defined environment
variable das wird auch funktionieren ja aber das das geht ich weiß dass das geht waste
system nein nein nein nicht compose ok machen was anderes docker update help ok nee anscheinend
funktioniert es wirklich nicht ich hätte ernsthaft gedacht dass das funktioniert das
hätte das ok das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass das dass man das gar ich ich bilde mir
echt ein dass das funktioniert dass man ein weimann variabels abdecken kann ich wir haben
nicht mal viel zeit ich suche ich suche trotzdem noch mal aber danach alter pepega kram pepega
kram an ok anscheinend anscheinend
ich will eigentlich in running container hätte gedacht man kann das man kann das ändern nachträglich
das weiß ich dass das funktioniert aber ich habe gedacht man kann die bestehende konfig
irgendwie ändern aber anscheinend anscheinend ist das nicht so anscheinend ist das nicht
so ok change values docker inspekt vielleicht findet man darüber was ist it possible to
edit data returned by docker inspekt nee nicht so direkt ja ok das das würde funktionieren
docker update ahja nflist was ist das ich sag doch dass das funktioniert docker update
update welche dockerversion hab ich version 2010 es sollte eigentlich dabei sein haben
die ihre hilf haben die einfach nur ihre helb datei nicht aktualisiert dafür docker update
minus e was wollen wir haben wird WordPress host gleich war dann muss man das überhaupt so angeben in
dem muster oder muss dazu erst der der container name noch hin update WordPress
das gibt warum warum ist das da drinne in dem beispiel von dem dude und warum ist das in meinem
docker nicht drinne der container namen ist vorne was ist das hier warum gibt es das net
anzeige ist raus warum warum kann das mein container hier nicht na gut egal wir haben
nicht mehr viel zeit docker stop was haben wir hier WordPress WordPress set kann man eigentlich
davon kann man eigentlich davon neu neu erstellen ok docker stop hat er namen WordPress
docker run WordPress set funktioniert das jetzt prinzipiell ok ja blablabla ist gut nervlich
rum gehe aus kackel man so auch noch drei minuten leute das wird knapp ok port mappings brauchen
wir noch war da mal konnte man nicht einfach sagen verwende das neu wie es ist also doch
heran WordPress set wir brauchen ohne set nee nicht ohne set und das hier schon das schon
richtig so minus e ich kann mir mit die synthax nicht merken wie man das da reinschreibt minus
e WordPress host gleich hat man das so so kann man so kann man glaube ich invalid option
das weiß doch keiner aus dem kopf mann minus e ist auch richtig minus e oder muss
ich minus minus nf machen minus minus nf ok meinetwegen minus minus nf in der beschissung
ist da nichts drinne habe ich das mache ich das irgendwie verkehrt nee das ist doch das
ist doch im prinzip richtig invalid option nee warte mal ok ok ok complete WordPress
no wp config found das ist auch ok ok alles klar vielleicht vielleicht gehts jetzt vielleicht
gehts jetzt port mappings fehlen port mappings fehlen shit docker stop wie hab ich das ding
jetzt wird knapp leute das wird knapp monke es p fack ich hab vergessen wo muss wo muss
der das laufen von 80 80 auf 80 80 ok 80 80 ok jetzt karl ah shit was war der test
scheiß mann ich fack mann ich seh meinen browser nicht wegen diesem dreck da oben alter
was ist was ist der test hier fack ok das geht nicht aber wenn das heißt nicht WordPress
ich hab den container falsch geplant ok wir müssen wir müssen es glaube ich gleich
nochmal machen weil gleich die session wegfliegt ok wir sind wir sind nämlich über wir sind
nämlich über der zeit wir sind wir sind über der zeit drüber vielleicht vielleicht kriegen
wir es noch kurz kurz hin also stopp nochmal stoppen jetzt hab ich die ganzen mister gestartet
hä warum läuft der nimmer was ist denn da los warum läuft der docker container nicht
mehr run was ist da los was ist da los warum geht der nimmer was invalid option ach
ok so jetzt geh aus geh aus geh aus ist gut minus d ach quatsch ok zu spät f ok noch
mal aufmachen aber wir wissen jetzt ja wie es funktioniert das ist es ist nur eine idee
wenn man drauf gekommen ist ist eigentlich ganz einfach pass auf der hat noch irgendwas
anderes eingebaut der hat garantiert noch irgendwas anderes eingebaut das ist nicht
jetzt also ohne weiteres funktionieren ok zack ok so und minus ich zum glück habe ich mir
das copy pasted zwingen das docker stopp wordpress oder docker am wordpress sogar docker am wordpress
docker run n minus d und dann ist es name nee es ist tag oder tag stopp ja tt zumindest
mein docker bild ist ist es tag ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
warum läuft das shit nicht
ist doch nicht minus t ich habe das image net gelöscht docker name container es ist
doch minus minus name es ist doch minus minus name weil beim bild beim bild ist es auf jeden
fall tag ok schon besser ja ja ok minus d jetzt sollte der kram auch laufen ok jetzt
ist gut ok ok karl karl lokal host das sieh gut aus dass sie gut aus und so doch ich sage
Ah die IP ist bestimmt anders jetzt, docker, inspect, wir haben ja den Server neu gestartet,
varia db, nee, ok, docker, exec, WordPress, nee er sagt ja, er sagt ja,
server host, mysql, das ist aber verkehrt, der sollte doch jetzt eigentlich die IP benutzen,
wenn man das so angibt, ok, docker, exec, WordPress, bash, nee ok, docker, so rum ist
was man, bash, enf, WordPress, host, ist doch drinnen, ist das, benutzt man das nicht oder?
Die WP, WP-config-pap, das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken, ja, etc, wo ist das,
steht das hier, etc, ah hier, var, www wahrscheinlich, war, www, ah da sind wir ja schon
drinne, WP-config-pap, natürlich, kein Wimp, was sonst, wie soll ich das denn bitte schön
anzeigen lassen, ok, nice, das ist natürlich toll hier drinne jetzt zu scrollen, nein die können
sich nicht intern auflösen, weil die auf der default-bridge liegen und da gibt es keine
namensauflösung, so, db-name, WordPress, WordPress, db-passwort, ja das wird ja überschrieben,
aber wie kommt der auf, WordPress, db-host, mysql, habe ich das irgendwie anders geschrieben,
also weil hier überschreibt es das ja anscheinend auch oder, ich meine, ich könnte die Datei
jetzt editieren hier drinne und ein neues Image davon machen, WordPress, db-host, Timer
läuft nicht, ja wurscht, das juckt dem nicht, oder, ja es ist, ja es ist schon ein WordPress
Problem, der erzählt uns ja auch was von Environment Variablen, also wir könnten ein eigenes Netzwerk
machen, wo wir die dran hängen, ok, also WordPress interessiert es auf jeden Fall nicht, ich
meine, wir können da reingehen, achso wir haben keinen Editor, boah, Alter, ist das
nervig, mann, so, in vi vielleicht, es ist ja nichts drauf, seht, seht ist drinne, Leute,
jetzt, high IQ seht Action, da ist es nix drauf, seht, seht, ok, 5 hat sehtime, catwp-config,
ok, was, was müssen wir austauschen, da steht was von Home Admin, äh, Home Admin gibt sich,
home admin, ne, der meint, war, WWW, HTML, achso warte mal zeig ich mal was, äh, was
fühle ich ihn eigentlich aus, achso, ok, ok, Moment, sudo docker exac WordPress, ich muss,
muss die namensauflösung fixen ok ich muss die namensauflösung fixen das heißt ich muss ein
eigenes netzwerk erstellen ich gehe mal davon aus interessiert sich mal dobe frage interessiert
sich in docker container für meine lokalen host also könne ich könne ich da so was eintragen
bei skl ne ok das system egal also muss ich wahrscheinlich so was waren docker netzwerk
create oder so was netzwerk aber das kann man auch bestimmt exaq
pass mal auf wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt 6 hat 6 hack trick ich meine es ist zwar weg
nach dem reboot aber warum nicht ja wir können es wir können sie einfach mal ausprobieren
echo was brauchen wir 172 my sql das wird funkt das wird schon funktionieren easy easy
korrekt alles klar easy gelöst ich glaube nicht dass das die beste ich glaube nicht
dass das ist wie er sich das ganze vorgestellt hat ich glaube nicht dass es so gedacht ist
dass zuletzt zu lösen also ich gehe davon aus wir sollen wahrscheinlich so was machen
wie docker netzwerk create keckel und dann sollen wir die kisten dort reinpacken und
wenn die dort reingepackt wurden dann können die sich auch untereinander auflösen das
ist das ist wahrscheinlich der gewollte weg ok wir haben es geschafft lösung ist alles
gut so checken wir mal die clues die clues was wir machen soll ok erste aufgabe muss
man sagen wo wir es nicht nicht in der zeit hingekriegt haben ok we can connect to password
username password das password aber rausgekriegt das haben wir auch gemacht so so ähnlich so
ähnliche sachen ok ok from the name the user so wordpress db host or wordpress db name
home the first word is the default wordpress das ist ja auch richtig gewesen the default
database host vor wordpress db host ist meist ja but this host is not defined does not reach
maria db skl container ja aber wie man das jetzt die namensauflösung fixen soll sagt
er nicht na geil super tolle tolle lösung ok also nachdem es keine offizielle lösung
gibt haben es vollkommen korrekt gefixt mit einem editieren der host datei im laufenden
container also das würde ich nicht empfehlen das ganze so zu machen da hätten wir nämlich
auch genauso gut mit einem set an wordpress konfig rangehen können oder das ganze in
einem volume starten oder was auch immer und die datei editieren das hätten wir auch machen
können wir hätten auch wir hätten auch das ganze mounten können wordpress und hätten
dann die die datei editieren können auf dem host stimmt stimmt das ding hieß maria db
nicht my skl aber das egal der kann es trotzdem nicht auflösen selbst wenn das ding maria
db hieß weil die waren auf der default bridge und die default die default bridge hat keine
namensauflösung ok ja das war jetzt schon es war schon ein bisschen schwieriger dahinter
zu kommen more scenarios was zeigt man was kommt als nächstes wir machen einfach hier
weiter so als nächstes haben wir wtf it also folgende aufgabe schwer doch kann er fast
das wäre wahrscheinlich die richtige lösung gewesen doch der netzwerk machen die dinger
rein hängen und sich auflösen lassen ja es gibt eine binär datei unter home admin wtf
it wir machen jetzt einfach weiter damit von
der niemand weiß oh secret leute jetzt ich bitte euch jetzt darum das nicht zu weiter
zu erzählen ok wir wollen nicht dass damit irgendwie irgendwelche bösen heckermans was
mit anfangen können mit dieser info also es gibt eine binär datei unter home admin wtf
it von der niemand weiß wie sie funktioniert oder das kenne ich das kommt öfters vor datalen
wo niemand war also aus dingern wo niemand weiß wie sie funktionieren wenn natürlich
auf euren servan binary dateien spawnen von denen niemand weiß wie sie funktionieren ist
meistens verdächtig wie sie funktioniert oder was sie tut jemand erinnert sich daran
dass wtf mit einem dienst kommunizieren muss um zu starten führen sie dieses wtf program
aus damit es sich nicht mit einem fehler beendet und dinge repariert oder umgeht die sie brauchen
die aber auf diesem selber nicht funktionieren beachten sie dass sie mehrere web terminals
öffnen können ja oder er macht ein t-max drauf alles klar also auf geht's wtf wird
geben wie viel zeit haben wir da zwanzig minuten ok auf geht's jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
was darum kommt oder was dabei was dabei rauskommt warum nicht 18 weil ich keine zweite umfrage
gemacht habe ich meine wir haben zeit leute guck mal es ist erst 20 uhr wir kriegen noch
ein bisschen was wir kriegen noch ein bisschen was auf die bayer bei der ersten hast du gesagt
dass du die 18 machten ich habe gesagt ich mache eine zweite umfrage und dann gucken
was rauskommt und ich habe keine zweite umfrage gemacht deswegen war jetzt einfach weiter
mit 14 und außerdem lasst euch mal nicht so sehr zubeten wenn ich ihre irgendwelche abstimmung
mache das heißt noch lange nicht dass ich mich daran halten muss nur weil ich in abstimmung
gemacht habe alter ist das ding bald mal erstellt
meine beiden büsis aus dem tierheim sind seit gestern bei mir was sind büsis hundesorte
katzensorte ok wir haben es geschafft ok starten starte das verdammte spiel wtf it legt dem
heimatverzeichnis so home admin da legt eine datei wtf it ok wtf it was ist denn das es
ist ein go binary oh leute play singly fast written in go wobei das geht nicht das geht
nur in rust ein go binary haben wir da am start ausführbar ist das ganze nicht so wie
es aussieht das natürlich auch nicht kann sich mal ausprobieren ok also ausführbar
ist das ganze auch nicht ch mod plus x wtf it what
was haben wir denn hier bin bash gibt es da noch was anderes drauf
ok da ist natürlich nichts gesetzt user bin ch mod nee wo wo wo ist was kannst du angeblich
was user bin was
habe ich mich da vorhin verschrieben
an die permission permission die night ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ich hab ne Idee
ähm chmod
chmod geht nicht
aber
war chmod
nicht teil von der shell
nee
ist im moment
mal reingucken
ok das ist aber auch das richtige
das ist nicht irgendein chbait shit
das ist tatsächlich
chmod
gab es da
gab es doch nen trick
wartet mal leute
sixhead time
also ich hab mehrere ideen
wir könnten chmod
über python oder so
aufrufen
das könnten wir machen
oder
es gab nen trick
passt mal auf
cat
ok wir machen jetzt
wir machen jetzt mal was kaputt
ok moment
memusage
wunderbar topprogramm
das brauch ich cp memusage
memusage.bug
also cat
chmod
und wir überschreiben damit
memusage
easy
nee fuck doch nicht
shit
doch doch doch doch doch es hat
funktioniert es hat funktioniert
wir haben
executable draus gemacht
nice
ok
memusage
ist jetzt unser chmod
also können wir chmod löschen
mv memusage nach chmod
und mv memusage
back
wieder zurück nach memusage
ok
nice nice nice
ok chmod plus o
haha
python
das geht aber nur wenn was
anderes kaputt macht
Leute wisst ihr woher ich das weiß
als ich Azubi war
hat mich irgenso ein
ich weiß nicht mal genau wer es gewesen ist
es war aber einer der admins dort die extrem
die mir wirklich auf den sack gegangen sind
der hatte einmal irgenso ne komische
aufgabe für mich
und ich hab es nicht auf die reihe gekriegt
weil es
irgendwie sowas ähnliches war
und da hat er mir dann erklärt ok
aber solang du quasi schreibrechte
hast kannst du dir quasi
jedes executable
machen
wäre das
ok also chmod plus
x wir müssen uns mal weiter home
home
admin
wtf it
easy
haha
andreas
das coole ist wir machen den kram ja
beide schon recht lange
aber irgendwie
gibts immer was was man
nicht weiß und umgedreht
das ist halt wirklich
man lernt da nie aus
ok kennt openconfig file
ich seh da
kein config file
ok strace time
was macht das ding
was macht das hier hier das versucht
da zu öffnen home admin
wtf
it config punkt konf
was ist da mit dem
mem usage genau passiert
leute ich markier mir mal
ich markier sag ich gleich ich will die
zeit nicht überschreiten sag ich gleich was zu
touch
ok wtr fit
cant connect
och please nicht
wieder irgendein dns shit
man
ich mach mir schon mal ein zweites
terminal auf ich hab da ich hab da so
ich hab da so meine
meine vermutung was jetzt gleich was
jetzt gleich kommen wird
wir müssen herausfinden
wo er sich hin verbindet das heißt wir müssen
entweder einen tcp dump machen oder wir sehen
es im strace
ich hoffe oh nein ich habs
geleakt
schnell leute bevor es welche abtippen
keckel
wer sich die mühe macht
das sich jetzt rauszusuchen
also wtf
im strace
im strace steht nix
nix drinne
config
datei operation cant connect
zu server ok
also sudo
minus i tcp dump
keine namensauflösung
wow
nope
tcp dump not port
ssh
ehm
not port
ok ausführen
cant connect zu server
ah das geht bestimmt
da moment moment
wir müssen nicht auf dem interface lau
also wir müssen nicht das netzwerkkarte mitsniffen
wir müssen loopback wahrscheinlich mitsniffen
vermute ich jetzt einfach mal stark an der stelle
da guck an
was haben wir denn da
port 777
so so port 777
also netcat
minus listen
minus port 777
und was passiert da wtf
ja da schau an
wtf
macht ein http get request
auf port 777
der go
http client
das heißt ich vermute
mal wir brauchen da wahrscheinlich
ein vim etc engine x
eh engine x
konf ich hab jetzt einfach mal
geraten ob das ein engine x ist weil
wobei brauchen wir nicht wir können auch
ganz einfach wobei
vielleicht erwartet er ja was spezielles
engine x konf gucken wir mal
eh ne
engine x
engine x sides
enabled
default
port 80 ist schonmal debated
overrated brauchen wir nicht
in der index file
einfach in index file ok
wir machen das einfach
so
www.atml
zack
port 777
scheiß auf engine x
tc
spies
es geht easy
gelöst
checked my solution
easy as fuck
get
Ich war auf die offizielle lösung gespannt
Also um das doch mal um das noch mal zusammen zu fassen
History
Um das zusammen zu fassen als allererstes
Mussten wir irgendwie raus bekommen warum wir zahm nicht verwenden können und sie hat selbst keine exekutable rechte was eigentlich nie
Vorkommt radion tracer lang ist nur für den sub was nie vorkommt das heißt wir mussten erst mal das ganze ein bisschen austricksen das
ch mod funktioniert
Dann haben wir mit strays rausgekriegt dass wtf it eine konfig datei möchte nämlich eine wtf it konf punkt konf
konfig punkt konf
Dann haben wir mit einem tcp damp rausgekriegt dass es sich versucht zu einem lokalen server auf port 7 7 7 zu verbinden
Und dann haben wir einen lokalen server hatte tp dass es in web request macht haben wir netcat rausgekriegt
Und dann haben wir einfach einen server erstellt
Der auf port 7 7 7 lauscht und das reicht dem programm wohl schon dass es läuft ok nice sudo power off
bäm
Gut jetzt kann ich also ah ne ne ne ne ne ne hier
Next wir gucken uns die offiziellen
die offizielle hilfe dazu an
dieser mod ist nur der exekutiv das ist ein fun
unrealistisch problem das stimmt ich habe das noch nie erlebt dass zehr mod selbst nicht executable ist
Ich hätte übrigens auch eine andere idee gehabt wie man das lösen könnte und zwar wäre das ein python script gewesen was zehr mod auf ruft
weil
pyson ruft ja nicht
zehr mod des terminal kommando auf sondern die z mod
Implementierung, also das kernel interface für ch-mod das heißt es hätte auch funktionieren können
Aber so ist natürlich besser so nächst
Guck was
Ich vermute mal das ist so was ähnliches wie was er hier macht oder oder was
Lipp vier
Was
Habe ich im leben noch nicht verwendet
Okay, wir fragen was der golf das hat er bestimmt von stack over flow oder sowas sehr motz selbst
Itself not executable
Haut uns her motz mit hauze her motz
Okay, schauen wir mal das hat er hier her hier hat er das her
Das hat er von stack overflow oder tut 100 pro das weiß doch aus dem kopf keiner
Das weiß doch das war so seriously das weiß doch keiner ja hier
Ach ja guck mal da und pearl da wissen wir doch auch schon gleich aus welcher stack overflow antwort er die idee hierfür gezogen hat
Aber ihr müsst zugeben leute ihr müsst zugeben
Meine lösung die hier nicht drinne steht für das problem die war noch besser oder
Mit dem überschreiben mit dem überschreiben von mem usage
So was haben wir als nächstes lösung
You can't open config file you need to introspekt the cold sama was ist das für eine kack playlist ist doch die playlist ich immer hab
You need to introspekt cold
You need to introspekt the cold or the sister ah wir hätten eins hätten wir noch machen können leute wir hätten noch
Ah moment mal gucken ob das noch geht fack ich hab schon ausgedacht wir hätten strings machen können wir hätten strings machen können auf die go datal
Gucken ob da irgendwas interessantes drinstehen
Okay
Soluzion
Do as trace and towards the end you see entry ja das haben wir gesehen genau no such das habe ich das habe ich auch gefunden
Can't connect to server you need to look in the network for where the program is trying to communicate ja das habe ich gemacht mit dem tcp damp
run tcp damp ok
Das schlägt er auch vor minus loop back genau auf die idee bin ich dann auch gekommen
Nordport
Auf die idee ok das hätte ich aber gar nicht gebraucht das hätte ich gar nicht gebraucht wenn ich lupe gemacht hätte
Aber gut zumindest sieht man dass ich nicht so weit weg von der offiziellen lösung war außer das hier oben das habe ich ganz anders gemacht
777 ja das habe ich gefunden
Ja und das habe ich ach guck mal
Ja
Der hat sogar das gleiche drin
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht ich hätte jetzt gedacht dass der das mit mit dem engine x oder so macht ok der hat genau das gleiche drin
vorgabe
Ich habe das nur benutzt weil ich das noch in der historie drin hatte und ich nicht suchen musste danach
also
Erstaunlicherweise muss man sagen waren wir doch sehr nah an der muster lösung dran außer beim ersten schritt
Da waren wir meilenweit von der muster oder von der von dem offiziellen lösungsweg entfernt
Aber wirklich meilenweit entfernt
Ok nice hat funktioniert next was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes
Das machen wir nicht ich habe keinen bock auf noch mehr docker und kopern ist jetzt
Hongkong ok chat ihr wollt alle die 18 oder
So habe ich das habe ich das vorhin richtig verstanden ihr wollt alle die 18 haben heck a web server
Auf dem zweiten rechner bestimmt die löse jetzt verraten nicht alles mensch die 15
Ne die 15 war jetzt nicht 16
Vorhin hat in der abstimmung gestanden 18 kommen nachdem es die leute schon beschwert haben dass nicht die 18 drangekommen ist
Ach so mit dem ch mod ja genau deswegen habe ich mir das extra hier markiert dass ich was zu sagen kann
was auch immer
Was ist mit dem m usage genau passiert also
Was ich gemacht habe ist folgendes ich zeige ich zeige es dir ich zeige es dir lokal mal mk dir kakas
Ich habe eine datei wir können ja genauso nennen ich habe eine datei mehr m usage die hat rechte was hatten die für rechte gehabt
755 oder so ist auch egal m usage und ich habe eine datei
ch mod
Und die hatte
555 oder so
Egal also du hast du hast zwei dateien. Ich
Ach moment nicht 54 will ich doch haben mensch nicht
fünf
Okay, also du hast du hast eine datei die ist
executable und du hast eine datei die ist nicht executable aber du hast recht
Also das ist wichtig du hast schreibrechte auf beide datei auf auf die executable datei
Das ist wichtig also diese datei muss ausführbar sein und du musst schreibrechte darauf haben
Sonst funktioniert das an der stelle nicht
Man kann glaube ich
Auch irgendwie tricksen wenn die datei executable ist aber zumindest das ist nicht so wichtig
Auch irgendwie tricksen wenn die datei executable ist aber zumindest das ist in dem fall das ist in dem fall wichtig du musst du
Du musst schreiben können in die datei so und was ich jetzt mache ist folgendes ich gebe mir den inhalt dieser datei aus
Ch mod das ist binary das ist egal also das komme jetzt komme jetzt weg ich kann ja theoretisch sogar
Einfach mal mein ch mod hier hinkopieren um es zu zeigen
Ach so ich habe keine right permissions okay
Okay
Und jetzt haben wir ch mod auf
Ch mod
Ch mod 4 4 4 auf ch mod okay alles klar
Okay jetzt haben wir das ganze das haben wir das ganze nachgestellt also ich gebe das hier aus mit cat
Das bringt natürlich nichts weil das ist binary gedürnt guck
Also das das besteht ja das besteht ja aus binary shit also wenn ich das auf die kommando zeile auf
Auf gel ausgeben bringt das nichts aber was ich machen kann ist ich kann den inhalt der datei ausgeben und dann
Ich kann
Redirecten
In eine datei
Die executable rechte hat das funktioniert aus folgendem grund
Ich habe right rechte auf die datei und durch das
Quasi überschreiben mit neuem inhalt
ändert sich die ändern sich die rechte der datei nicht weil die datei ist schon angelegt die gibt es im
Pfeilsystem die pfeilsystem rechte sind gesetzt ich ändere nur den inhalt
Das ist quasi ich kopiere ch mod in mem usage rein ich ersetze den inhalt
Und dementsprechend bleiben wenn man sich das hier anguckt übrigens
Habe ich jetzt auf einmal hier in den ch mod der executable ist
Guck da ist es also das ist das ist wirklich feifert
Ok weiter im text wir machen jetzt 18 also was haben wir noch offen danach 16 17 jetzt haben wir 18
Es gibt ein geheimnis also wieder wieder nix verraten
Er geht web server also wir gucken uns mal kurz die aufgabe an
Es gibt ein geheimnis das in einer datei gespeichert ist die der lokale apache web server bereitstellen kann
finden sie dieses geheimnis und speichern sie es in der datei
Home admin secrets nee secret.txt
Ab ja beachten sie dass auf diesem server der benutzer admin kein sudo ist ok das heißt wir können
Auch wenn der user admin heißt nicht root werden
Beachten sie auch dass die password knacker hashcat hydra und aus den paketen
Nee und und hydra aus den paketen installiert sind und die binär dateien von john the ripper aus den quellen in home admin john run
Erstellt wurden ok hacker mann time jetzt angesagt
Auf gehts
Das wird teuer für ihn auf aws
Wenn wir jetzt erstmal password password crack dinger darauf lassen laufen lassen naja gut die
Passwörter werden wahrscheinlich so lang sein dass man sie nicht einfach ausprobieren kann
Aber mit so einem tool wahrscheinlich innerhalb von der sekunde durchprobiert sind
Wenn überhaupt also der wird der wird sich bestimmt nicht in unserem stürzen nur dass wir hier ein bisschen rumbasteln dürfen
No gods, no god no no no no
Ich meine wir könnten jetzt einfach uns über einen Hetznerserver oder sowas tunneln.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich mein ey, der Typ stellt das kostenlos zur Verfügung.
Der muss jede vm bezahlen ohne, ohne dass es uns was kostet.
Ich glaube, das ist der Zeitpunkt wo ich sagen würde, wir könnten es zwar easy umgehen machen
das aber nicht, das wird eines der kleinsten AWS Kisten sein, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
so teuer.
Das wird den wahrscheinlich ein paar Euro im Monat kosten, ich denke nicht, dass es
so teuer ist, da sind die kleinsten AWS Kisten jeweils nur für ein paar Minuten an, selbst
wenn das mal im Monat 300, 400 Leute machen wird das nicht so viel kosten.
Im Prinzip wird der John auf das Root Passwort losgelassen und dann gehts weiter.
Ich hab noch keine Ahnung, vielleicht, vielleicht müssen wir uns auch root, wobei, du kannst
den nicht so einfach auf das Root Passwort loslassen, weil der den Root Passwort nicht
besitzt.
Und Shadow, also die Shadow Datei ist ja normalerweise nicht readable für normale User, ja das müssen
wir dann schauen, aber das geht anscheinend nicht, also das heißt wir haben morgen noch
drei Sachen, also ein streng genommen vier, weil wir haben ja Kubernetes Web App Not Working
nicht gemacht.
Ja ne, dann machen wir, ich probiers nochmal, vielleicht dürfen wir den ja machen, ne auch
nicht.
Ok, ne, das respektieren wir und machen das heute nicht, tunnel, dann tunnel ich mich
nicht drüber.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche spannende Sachen chat, die wir klären müssen, ungrägliche
Sixhead Themen, achso Unix Porn wollten wir uns hier angucken, da haben wir doch jetzt
noch was, was wir machen können, im Discord, ja du hast recht hab ich gar nicht dran gedacht,
im Discord gibt es einen, also in meinem Discord gibt es einen Channel, mach das mal kurz full
screen, der nennt sich, wo hab ich denn meinen Discord hier überhaupt, der ist in den Builder
Only Channels und nennt sich Unix Porn, da posten Leute ihre Desktops bzw. ihre gestylten
Linux Oberflächen, das heißt gucken wir uns das ganze jetzt mal an, ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht mehr wo wir stehen geblieben sind, ah beim Zarex sind wir stehen geblieben,
beim Zarex sind wir stehen geblieben, ok schauen wir uns das ganze mal an, gehen wir in die
NVM rein und ich öffne mal die Bilder, openen Browser, openen Browser, gut also da haben
wir den Desktop vom Zarex, lasst uns das ganze mal kurz uns zur Gemüde führen, es sieht
aus wie ein I3 würde ich sagen, du hast eine sehr schöne Leiste hier oben, ich tippe darauf
Zarex, dass das I3 Status RS ist, das können wir übrigens zumachen, I3 Status RS, yep,
yep dick, genau, hast du aber schön gemacht mit der Leiste, vor allem auch die Icons,
ich glaube das ist ein Standard Gnome Icon Set, wobei ne das sind Emojis, das sind gar
keine Icons, aber trotzdem ein Standard Gnome Icon Set, wo blick, oh nein wo blick, was
ist denn jetzt schon wieder geleakt, also die Leiste ist schick, hier oben hast du wahrscheinlich
deine GitHub Pull Requests oder irgendwie sowas, weiß ich genau, sehr schicke CPU Auslastung
übrigens, schicker als meine muss ich sagen, meine CPU Auslastung sieht man hier nur hier,
also so nen Craft, wer auch schon, Leute das schreibe ich mir als auf, das machen wir,
ein Modul, bisschen Python üben wieder, Custom Modul, CPU Auslastung mit Craft als ASCII,
also CPU Auslastung, Temperatur, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur Status Anzeige Temperatur, ok nicht
ok, Speicher, Docker Container, ist das mittlerweile standardmäßig dabei in E3 Status Rust, Docker
Container, oder hast du das irgendwie selbst gebaut, Audio Lautstärke, du hast nen Timer,
sehr schön, ist der Timer auch mittlerweile dabei bei E3 Status RS, oder hast du auch
selbst nen Timer gebaut, ok und das ist die Anzeige, das kenne ich, ist alles dabei, vielleicht
soll ich das tatsächlich wieder verwenden, ich mein wenn da alles eingebaut ist, wenn
da alles eingebaut ist, was ich haben will, vielleicht soll ich dann einfach das benutzen,
egal, hast du schick gemacht, die Status Leiste gefällt mir, als nächstes gucken wir uns
den Desktop an, wo er seine Terminals hat, ok also Neo Fetch, natürlich was sonst, ich
hatte übrigens recht, das sind die Default Gnome Icons, ok Terminal, Terminal, Terminal
und natürlich Wubblos Twitch auf, so muss das sein, Hollywood auch ganz wichtig, dass
das ganze mehr Hackermans aussieht, schönes Farbschema hast du am Start, schönes Terminal
Farbschema, Hackfond, was ist das für nen Terminal, sieht ein bisschen aus von der Hintergrundfarbe
her wie meins, ist das auch Tomorrow Night oder was ist das für nen Terminal Farbschema,
was hast du da am Start, achso du hast gar kein, du hast nichts custom gesetzt, das ist
was fertiges, was dabei ist, oder welches Farbschema veränderst du im Terminal, oder
ist es bei aller Kritik dabei, aber find ich schick, kann ich auch mitarbeiten, ok Next,
da haben wir als nächstes, wo ist denn das nächste Desktop, hier, der Shryker, schau
wir da, ja aber noch letztens erst, der hat jetzt auch Windows am Start, Moment, es heißt
Unix Porn, nicht Windows Porn, ach du hast die Farben selbst verändert, hast du das dich
an irgendwas orientiert Sarix oder hast du einfach was genommen was dir gefällt, Windows,
da ist das wieder G-Bait und ist nur ne Linux was aussieht wie in den Windows, ich traue
ich traue diesen Screenshots immer nicht, WinFetch in PowerShell, ok also es sieht schon
an der Moment sind auch Games und alles drauf, also ich vermute mal es ist tatsächlich in
Windows, oder ein gut gefaktes Linux, weil die Shell sieht ein bisschen anders aus als
die offizielle Terminal App, aber die kann man ja vielleicht auch stylen, vielleicht
ist es auch ein anderes Terminal, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es auch G-Bait, ich kann es
jetzt nicht beurteilen ob es ein echtes Windows ist oder ein Linux was aussieht wie Windows,
kein Linux hat Internetverknüpfung im Launcher, das stimmt es heißt nicht Internetverknüpfung,
das ist schon richtig, jo, es sieht aber für Windows Verhältnisse ganz gut aus, muss
man sagen, ok wir haben als nächstes wieder den Shryker, der ist ja richtig hartnäckig
hier, als nächstes gucken wir uns das, Sekunde, das vom Shryker an, offensichtlich ein, ja
das ist ziemlich Default oder, nur dass du keine Leiste bei deinem Gnome hast, ist das
überhaupt ein Gnome, was ist denn das, ich würde sagen von Icons und der Leiste und
allem ist das ein Gnome, aber du hast zumindest oben kein Startmenü, sondern nur unten die
normale Leiste, dafür hast du deinen Launcher unten auf der Leiste drauf, es könnte vielleicht
ja was anderes sein, was ist es denn hier, zeig mal hier, ja es ist ein Gnome, sieht
aber auch ganz schick aus, das muss man den Gnome Leuten lassen, Gnome sieht Default
mäßig ganz ok aus, aber ich mag Gnome überhaupt nicht von der Bedienung, das ist halt das
Ding, also ich mag übrigens KDE auch nicht, ich mag eigentlich keine Desktop Oberfläche
unter Linux, ich mag auch übrigens die Windows Oberfläche nicht und die Mac Oberfläche
stört mich bestimmt auch genug dran, das einzige mit dem ich halbwegs klar komme ist
I3, weil es einfach nichts macht, weil es einfach nicht nervt, es ist einfach nur da,
aber standardmäßig sieht es wenigstens gut aus, auch wenn ich nicht mag zu benutzen,
ja schick, was gab es für eine Frage eben im Chat, was war, angepasst, das Rollrad meiner
Maus hat ziemliche Input-Lags in einer VM, ist interessanterweise nicht bei allen, das
hast du eine Idee woran das liegen könnte, eh gut Forever Tools hast du bestimmt drauf,
die hat er, Forever Tools hat er bestimmt drauf, was kann man da einstellen, nee ich
glaube nicht, dass es da dran liegt, warte mal Edit, Preferences und dann was, nee, was,
nee ist doch richtig oder, Options, nee hab keine Input, nee okay keine Ahnung wo ich
einstellen muss, settings, Options, Input, okay ich hab keine Ahnung wo diese Optionen
sein sollen, ach nee Advanced, Advanced da waren wir doch gerade, ach nee hier Advanced,
das gibt es, hier Input, Default, Default ist garantiert normal und nicht Low, Input
und Craft, nee das wird es nicht, das wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein, also du kannst
es ja mal ausprobieren, das glaube ich nicht, dass es daran liegt, also wenn du Forever
Tools installiert hast, in welcher, was betreibst du in der VM, ist das mit 3D Beschleunigung
Oberfläche, also ist das irgendwie ein Gnome oder ein KDE oder sowas, mit 3D Acceleration,
also du kannst es ja mal ausprobieren, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das was bringt, nee
dachte ich, hab mich auch gewundert, wenn das was bringt, was haben wir denn als nächstes,
oh Chat, das ist für euch, nächste, nächste, nächste Distro bzw. nächste Desktop Oberfläche,
das ist was für euch, das wird euch gefallen, das weiß ich jetzt schon, so das ist übrigens
die Oberfläche von Sebi aus dem Discord, Battlesheep ist es nur im Browser laggy, wenn es nur
im Browser laggy ist, versuch mal 3D oder Acceleration auszuschalten im Browser oder
es ist überall laggy unter Linux, ok, nee, dann weiß ich auch nicht, du könntest dein
Mausrad mit X Settings ein bisschen schneller stellen, nee, dann weiß ich jetzt auch grad
nicht, was du machen kannst, guck mal, was du ausprobieren kannst, ob es wirklich laggt,
mach Cat, ach Shit, mein Terminal crappt das, wenn du Cat machst in deinem Terminal und
du hast ein Terminal, was nicht scrollen kann, so X Term oder sowas, dann siehst du in Cat
bei jedem Mal scrollen den Input, oder du kannst auch X Def oder wie hieß das, X Probe
oder nee, es gibt auch ein Programm, da siehst du deine Inputs direkt, da kannst du sehen,
ob es laggt, X Show Inputs, wie heißt denn das, X Def, genau, ja das meine ich, da kannst
du drüber gehen und wenn du scrollst, siehst du direkt neben, machst du so, siehst du direkt
neben dein Input, da kannst du gut debuggen, ob alles funktioniert und wenn es dort laggt,
dann ist auf jeden Fall was mit deiner Maus Input kaputt oder mit deiner Maus drin, also
wenn das hier laggt beim Scrollen, dann weißt du auf jeden Fall, was kaputt, ansonsten
hast du die Chancen es irgendwie mit X Settings zu fixen, so also, Sebi's Desktop, Sebasu-chan,
alles klar, Extremely remote activated, er hat viel zu viel Transparenz im Terminal,
Leute, wie will man dieses Terminal benutzen, du siehst ja den Text kaum in dem Terminal,
das kannst du knicken, das siehst du gar nichts, ich mein, wenn er seinen Weep Hintergrund
auch beim Terminal schreiben braucht, soll mir das ja alles recht sein, aber du siehst
ja gar nichts, guck mal, was ist das für ein Kontrast für den Text, WM-Theme, kannst
du kaum erkennen, Sebasu-chan kannst du auch nicht richtig, also das ist eigentlich zu
viel Transparenz, man kann es, wie man bei mir im Hintergrund hier sieht, man kann ja
auch die Transparenz dezent machen, mein White Papo Happy scheint ja auch im Hintergrund
durch, allerdings nur ganz, ganz dezent, guck, das ist der richtige Hintergrund und hier
so ganz, ganz dezent durchs Terminal durch, das finde ich persönlich angenehmer, als
hier dieses Zeug so extrem Low Contrast, dafür muss ich sagen, passt die Farbgebung, auch
wenn ich dunkle Themes mit irgendwelchen roten Buttons und Eigens nicht wirklich mag, passt
das aber sogar ganz, ganz hübsch, erinnert mich ein bisschen an Material Design Farbgebung,
die hat so ein bisschen was, auch vom Farbton und sowas, aber das ist ganz nice, ich muss
aber sagen, für mich wäre das rot nix, sieht aber in dem Fall tatsächlich ganz schick
aus, Mac OS Fake Buttons und hinten hat er Visual Studio Code wahrscheinlich, ne, Supply
Text, all das habe ich ja schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, nur noch echte Weeps verwenden,
Supply Text, wie es scheint, Supply Texts, gibt es das mittlerweile, der war doch, war
doch Closed Source, oder, Supply Text, interessant, gibt es das noch Leute, gibt ihr das verwenden,
Tesla P4 Fan Control, ah hier will er seine Grafikkarte, den Lüfter steuern, Supply Text
funktioniert, ja das es funktioniert ist mir auch klar, aber ich glaube kaum einer benutzt
es noch, ja, also mein Fall ist es nicht, und nicht unbedingt wegen dem Weep Hintergrund
sondern wegen dem viel zu hohen, also geringen Kontrast in dem Fall im Terminal, so wen
haben wir denn als nächstes, Davokin, nicht Dovakin, Davokin, der Dev Operator aus dem
Twitch Chat, Force Champ, der Hintergrund kommt mir ja irgendwie bekannt vor, den du
da hast, ich frage mich wo her, ok gucken wir uns das ganze mal an, von Anfang, von
Anfang bis Ende, von hinten, ok also schönes, schöner Desktop, ist es i3, nee es ist was
anderes oder, nee doch es ist i3, ich glaube es ist i3, nur dass du keine UIs hast, und
dafür hast du die, hast du die, die Workspaces oben halt benannt, ja, sehr guter, sehr guter
Username, schau mal Username, KeckW, allerdings ist LulW immer noch größer, KeckW, Terminal
Farbschema ist nicht wirklich mein Fall, zu viel Grün, zu komisches, kack Orange, aber
jedem was sein Geschmack ist, fast angethämtes Hardtop, welche Leiste ist das, es ist nicht
die Default-Leiste auf jeden Fall, die Default-Leiste kann kein Volume und sonst was, Polybar, Aha,
Polybar, verstehe, verstehe, was haben wir hier, oh fuck jetzt bin ich mit dem Stuhl
übers Kabel gefahren, also was haben wir hier, Theme, Ultimate, Plata Dark, Endeavor OS,
Arch By The Way, sehr gute Wahl, Hackfond, ich sehe, ich sehe Hackfond ist sehr beliebt,
mal eine Frage an alle Leute, die Hack als Schriftart verwenden, habt ihr das von mir
aus im Stream, oder habt ihr das vorher schon gefunden, oder unabhängig von mir gefunden,
würde mich an der Stelle einfach mal interessieren, Stream, gut, dass ich das jetzt mal geöffnet
habe, im Stream, okay, Hack ist doch die Standard-Fond, nee Hack ist eigentlich nirgendswo die Standard-Fond,
Hackfond ist meistens Bitstream, Bitstream-Fonds oder Inconsolata oder Ubuntu Mono oder sowas,
aber Hack habe ich noch nirgendswo, seriously, bei nicht einer Distribution Default gesehen,
Comic Codes, naja, so, hast du den Hintergrund auch AI abscalen lassen aus dem Reddit-Post
oder wie bist du an deinen Hintergrund gekommen, die Transparenz, finde ich, geht gerade so
noch in Ordnung, weil du hast ja auch recht, also recht kontrastreiche Farben und sowas
hier im Terminal, auch AI abscalen, aber für mich wäre es trotzdem ein Tick zu viel Transparenz,
aber das geht auf jeden Fall, guck hier mal im Vergleich, es geht auf jeden Fall in die
richtige Richtung, man kann es, man kann es denke ich ganz gut benutzen, so, dann hast
du das ganze in einer VM laufen, EndeavorOS-PogChamp-Fond, ok, nächstes Bild von ihm, Rofi an der Seite,
mein Rofi ist in der Mitte, aber ansonsten auch sehr schick, hast du ein eigenes Theme
gemacht oder hast du was genommen, was dabei ist, bzw. dabei ist dieses Theme nicht, du
hast wahrscheinlich irgendwas von GitHub, bisschen editiert, warum ich Transparenz mag, weil
ich finde es ist schön anzugucken, was, Subversion, what, Subversion, ok, ich weiß nicht was ich
da habe, ich will es jetzt nicht weiter aufmachen, aber warum haben wir alles in der Welt, Subversion,
benutze ich auch nicht, Sekunde Leute, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was das ist, es
ist zwar die Streaming-VM, in der ich eigentlich nichts mache, was irgendwie geheim wäre,
aber ich muss das ganze mal kurz checken, was es ist, da steht nichts drin, da steht
nichts drin, ok Leute, ich habe wirklich keine, wisst ihr was das sein kann, ich weiß was
das ist, irgendein, irgendein Art User-Repo-Ding, was wir installiert haben, geht wahrscheinlich
über Subversion, das werden wir gleich mal wieder löschen, yes, fort damit, du streamst
über eine VM, zieht das nicht übel, viel Leistung, also erstens, nein es zieht nicht
übertrieben viel Leistung, VMs laufen heute auf jedem LoR 15 PC ziemlich gut und CPU-Performance
ist jetzt in der VM mehr oder weniger das gleiche wie im Host, aber nachher von abgesehen
selbst wenn es Performance ziehen würde, mein Rechner ist ja auch etwas übertrieben,
ich habe 64 Gramm, relativ viele CPU-Kerne, mehrere SSDs, eine HDD, also es reicht, es
ist auf jeden Fall selbst wenn es Leistung ziehen würde, hätte ich genug Reserven, aber
ganz nach abgesehen es zieht auch gar nicht wirklich viele Ressourcen, VM ist wunderbar,
außerdem stream ich nicht aus einer VM, ich streame eine VM, ich streame mit OBS unter
Windows, aber ich streame meine VM, aber OBS läuft nicht in der VM, ok, also wie gesagt
finde ich so ganz schick, auch wenn die Farben nicht wirklich meins wären, dein Rofi ist
auch ganz schick, hast du auf GitHub gefunden, ok, so jetzt sehen wir hier sein Multi, oh
ein Doom Emacs User oder Doom, ist das Emacs, ja, ein Doom Emacs User, das habe ich ja schon
lange nicht mehr gesehen, wird das überhaupt noch maintained, tatsächlich, ein Doom Emacs
User, also Doom ist so eine Config Sammlung für Emacs, für alle die keinen Bock haben
Emacs von Hand zu konfigurieren, was ich auch keinem übel nehmen kann, schöne, oh das finde
ich schick, das finde ich schick, wie hast du das hingekriegt, das ist deine, ah das ist
Polybar, Polybar kannst du wahrscheinlich Rounded Corners und so einstellen, gehe ich
mal von aus, das finde ich schick, Rounded Corners, das hat irgendwie was da oben, so
dann sehen wir hier ein paar Terminals, hier mit dem Hintergrund, hast du den Hintergrund
gewechselt oder hast du jetzt irgendwie automatisches Hintergrund Switching, ne oder wahrscheinlich
nicht, hier hast du auch wieder ein bisschen anderes Farbschema am Start, das gefällt
mir persönlich jetzt deutlich besser, ja hier unten hast du einen Hardtop und so, passt
ok, was haben wir als nächstes, ja einfach nur den Hintergrund mit deinen Desktops oben,
schick finde ich ganz nice, ach das ist als Anderes das Arch von der Arbeit, ja mein Linux
auf der Arbeit ist mittlerweile ziemlich langweilig, ich hab mittlerweile ein Ubuntu installiert
auf dem Notebook, ich wollte mir auch keinen großen Akt mehr machen, ich mein ich muss
das Notebook eh bald abgeben und bin eh bald weg dort, ich hab jetzt noch schnell ein Ubuntu
drauf gehauen und gut ist, auf dem alten Notebook hatte ich ja mein Arch drauf mit der Konfig
die es auch in GitHub gab, aber ich musste jetzt ja ein neues Notebook installieren und
ich wollte einfach, dass es irgendwie funktioniert und wollte mir jetzt für 3 Monate da keine
Arbeit mehr machen, ok also, wer haben wir als nächstes, nochmal, nochmal der Davokin,
der postet uns ein Jubantu, Jubantu, Jubantu oder auch einfach Ubuntu genannt, was die
korrektere Aussprache ist, was hat er denn hier am Start, also man muss, man muss, also
das Font Rendering von Ubuntu ist schon gut standardmäßig, da muss man immer ein bisschen
rumbauen bis man das so gut hinkriegt, da kann man sich nicht beschweren, also Fonts sehen
unter Ubuntu ein Tick besser aus als einfach nur Default, du hast es auf jeden Fall ordentlich
angepasst und nicht diese komische mistige Leiste hier neben, gibt es irgendjemand der
unter Ubuntu unter dem Ubuntu Default Desktop diese Leiste links mag, ich hab es so eingestellt
weil mir gefällt es überhaupt nicht, ich hab es aber auch nur eingestellt weil ich
keinen Bock hab mir noch Zeit reinzustecken in das Arbeitsnotebook, schickes Farbschema
das gefällt mir tatsächlich gut hier wie es aussieht, Arbeitskollege ja gibt immer
weird Champ Leute und das sieht so aus, ja das finde ich tatsächlich ganz ganz hübsch,
es ist ja auch nicht unsinnig die Taskleiste links zu haben, weil man hat ja nach links
und rechts so horizontal, wenn man es so will hat man ja quasi mehr Platz als so vertikal
aber ich mag es trotzdem nicht, also aus dem Gesichtspunkt wäre es eigentlich sinnvoll
es links zu machen, aber ja ich mag es trotzdem nicht, Geschmackssache, wir schaffen es Leute
eigentlich mit Dom nicht völlig zu verzweifeln, ja indem sie es einfach so benutzen wie es
Default mäßig ist, gehe ich mal von aus, was anderes hält es ja bei Gnome auch nicht
aus, aber wie gesagt ich mag auch KDE nicht, vielleicht haben wir Glück und es ist nicht
der nächste Tag, sondern fuck, okay müssen wir doch im nächsten Stream weitermachen,
ne das können wir jetzt nicht machen, Sway plus Arch plus NeoWim, ja dann postet, postet
mal im Discord, also wir sind fertig, ich bin alles durch was die Leute gepostet haben
an ihren Desktops, wenn ihr noch neue Desktops habt beziehungsweise gestylte, coole Oberflächen
muss es, der Channel heißt zwar Unix Porn bei mir auf dem Discord, aber ihr könnt meinetwegen
auch Mac und Windows posten wenn ihr wollt, aber es sollte schon jetzt nicht einfach nur
Default sein, weil da muss man, das ist ja langweilig, da muss man auch nicht posten,
sonst haben wir nix mehr zum gucken Ende der nächsten Streams, ich bin jetzt mit allem
durch, Windows Skins sehen doch immer kacke aus, ja die paar Windows Screenshots die wir
jetzt geguckt haben heute und das letzte Mal waren durchaus okay denke ich, man kann
Windows, man kann aber Windows auch bestimmt auch schick stylen, macht bloß kaum einer,
was ist Material Shell, ach Gnome, sieht dann Gnome so aus wie Material Design oder wie
darf man sich das vorstellen, das sind dann zwei Sachen zusammen die ich nicht mag, Gnome
mag ich nicht und Material Design mag ich mittlerweile auch überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ja also so siehts aus, was ist los Darkseid aktuell am Job suchen, Junior DevOps die wollen
echt nicht mehr bezahlen, wie viel Berufserfahrung hast du denn, also suchst du nur noch Junior
weil du denkst was anderes kriegst du nicht hin oder suchst du nach Junior weil du denkst
für andere Jobs gibt es nicht oder bist du wirklich Einsteiger und was hast du gemacht,
hast du Physi gelernt oder was sind so die Voraussetzungen, es ist wichtig, also wenn
es ums Gehalt geht ist es tatsächlich wichtig, also nicht nur die obvies Sachen wie Berufserfahrung
in welchen Bereichen kennt man sich aus, die Region ist auch sehr wichtig, du kannst auch
einen Screenshot hier posten ja, wie benutzt du Windows und Linux gleichzeitig, ich bin
auf dem Internet, suche deutschlandweit full remote, wie lang hast du Physi gelernt und
bist aktuell noch bei deinem normalen Arbeitgeber oder wie ist das, also bist du jetzt frisch
fertig und suchst was oder hast du ein bisschen Berufserfahrung, weil du kannst dich ja durchaus
auch als normaler Admin DevOps Engineer was auch immer in der Richtung bewerben, du musst
ja nicht zwangsläufig Junior davor stehen, dass die bei Junior nicht super krass bezahlen
würden, dann würde ich jetzt nicht mehr im Großen Gedanken machen, 5 Jahre Berufserfahrung
man, da brauchst du doch keine Junior Stelle mehr, die müssen doch mal ordentlich drauf
hauen, das geht ja nicht, 5 Jahre, da bist du, wenn du 5 Jahre was gemacht hast, bist
du doch kein Junior, also es sei denn du hast absolut keinen Plan, aber das glaube ich nicht,
sonst wärst du ja nicht hier im Stream, weil wir wissen ja, dass alle Leute hier im Stream
allein schon durch die ganzen Prime-Subscriptions Massify-AQ haben, ups, falsches Emote, du
hast keine Cloud, es ist doch egal, ob du Cloud-Erfahrung hast oder nicht, du kannst sagen,
das ist egal, ob du Cloud-Erfahrung hast, du kannst sagen, du kannst, das musst du nicht
nur sagen, das kannst du auch, du kannst dich schnell einarbeiten, also du kannst dir selbstverständlich
privat ein bisschen was angucken, guck dir ein bisschen Azure an, such dir eine Cloud,
deine Wahl aus, Azure gibt es beispielsweise Startguthaben, bei Google Cloud gibt es aber
auch Startguthaben, es ist überhaupt kein Ding und beschäftige dich ein bisschen damit,
du kannst dich ein bisschen mit Ansible beschäftigen, ein bisschen mit Terraform und solche Geschichten,
ist gar kein Ding, aber ganz im Ernst, wenn du 5 Jahre Erfahrung hast und dich schnell
einarbeiten kannst, ist das vollkommen egal und das würde ich denen auch sagen, also nicht,
dass es vollkommen egal ist, sondern dass du Cloud-Erfahrung hast, wenn du sagst schon,
du hast GitHub, Action und sowas, Erfahrung, kannst du jetzt sagen, du hast Cloud-Erfahrung
und vielleicht passt es jetzt nicht exakt auf diese Sachen, aber du kannst dich auch
schnell einarbeiten und du verfügst über, das habe ich auch gesagt im Vorstellungsgespräch,
die haben mich irgendwas komisches gefragt, ich hatte keine Ahnung, was die wollen, irgendwas,
was die da intern einsetzen, doch, ich kann mich nur an meine Antwort erinnern, es ging
auch darum, da habe ich zu ihnen gesagt, ja, aber selbst wenn man die Tools kennt, das
reicht, wenn du Ansible und Terraform ein bisschen Ahnung hast, schreib Cloud, du hast
Cloud-Erfahrung, das ist mehr Cloud-Erfahrung als die meisten anderen Leute haben und ich
habe denen sinngemäß sowas gesagt, selbst wenn man die Tools kennt, was ich eigentlich
eine ganz gute, ganz gut diplomatische Antwort zu finden im Nachhinein, selbst wenn man die
Tools kennt, also ich habe mit den Tools schon gearbeitet, aber selbst wenn man die Tools
kennt, heißt es ja noch lange nicht, dass man weiß, wie das jeweilige Unternehmen die
Tools einsetzt, also sprich selbst wenn ich weiß, wie ein Engine X funktioniert und hier
wird ein Engine X eingesetzt, heißt es ja noch lange nicht, dass ich weiß, was darüber
für Services laufen, warum das wie konfiguriert ist, das heißt bisschen Einarbeitung braucht
man da eh immer und wenn ich eins die letzten Jahre über gelernt habe, dann ist es Google
zu benutzen, also ich finde Sachen immer relativ schnell und kann mich meistens, das meiste
auch schnell einarbeiten, sowas kannst du sagen, das ist ehrlich, das stimmt auch und 100%
Match gibt es eh nicht, ich würde gar nicht nach, ich kann selbstverständlich auch nach
Junior gucken, aber auch als normale, suche nach Administration, suche nach DevOps Engineer,
suche nach keine Ahnung was ist alles noch für Linux Engineer und was es da alles gibt
und da muss was ran, also mit 5 Jahren Berufserfahrung, ich habe angefangen damals
ganz frisch nach der Ausbildung, aber das ist 10 Jahre, ne Quatsch nicht 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre
her, da habe ich angefangen mit 33.600, 33.500, 33.600, wenn man das jetzt hochrechnet ist
das glaube ich Inflationsbereinigt mäßig irgendwie sowas hier in dem Dreh und das ist
definitiv nichts für 5 Jahre Berufserfahrung, guck doch mal in Frankfurt in der Finanzbranche,
die suchen alle wie verrückt, wir gucken nächstes mal weiter, aber wann ist man denn Senior,
das kann man so pauschal gar nicht sagen, also erstmal Titel sind eh für'n Arsch, das
Gute ist aber, dass wenn die Senior Stelle ausschreiben, dann ist da zumindest auch
ein gewisses Senior Gehalt meistens mit verknüpft, zumindest im jeweiligen Kontext des Arbeitgebers,
manch einer findet das halt wahnsinnig hoch, für ihr internes Gehaltsverfüge vielleicht
ist es versus andere nicht hoch, aber wenn die Senior ausschreiben sind sie meistens
auch bereit ein bisschen mehr zu bezahlen, deswegen ist es gar nicht schlecht wenn sie
es davor schreiben und das kann man nicht pauschal sagen ab wann man Senior ist, Senior
ist man dann, wenn einer eine Senior Stelle ausschreibt, du dich drauf bewirbst und die
überzeugst, dass du gut passt da drauf, also das kann zwischen 5 und 10 Jahren wie auch
immer, also das ist halt, man sagt eigentlich sobald man einen Bachelor besitzt verfügt
man auch über den Titel Senior, nee Senior ist ja gar kein Titel, Senior ist Quatsch,
das ist Blödsinn, das stimmt nicht, Senior ist kein Titel, Senior ist quasi so ein Job
Prefix um so ein bisschen so die Erfahrungswerte der Leute, die sich da drauf bewerben schon
ein bisschen abzuklopfen, wir können es vielleicht am besten noch als Karriere Stufe beschreiben
wie auch immer, eigentlich wollen die damit bloß sagen, sie suchen immer mit vielen Berufserfahrungen,
aber ich bin der Meinung, dass die schon nach ein bisschen, also die suchen nach, das kommt
vom Arbeitgeber an und ich denke, dass die schon die meisten ein bisschen was anderes
im Kopf haben, wenn sie einen Senior bla bla bla suchen, ich glaube die suchen die meisten,
die meisten suchen nicht nur jemand, der schon lange Technikerfahrung hat, sondern den sie
im Zweifelsfall auch mal auf abteilungsübergreifende Meetings schicken können, wenn, oder zumindest
teamübergreifende Meetings schicken können, wenn es um Technologieauswahlprozesse geht
und sowas, also du bist nicht nur jemand, der Technik Ahnung hat, sondern der in der
Lage ist, das ganze auch ein bisschen noch zu verkaufen und vielleicht ein bisschen Manager
kompatibel zu reden nebenbei, Senior im klassischen Sinne ist schon so, wie du es meinst, mit
einigen Jahren Berufserfahrung, ja es muss halt einer dich für eine Senior Stelle einstellen
und dementsprechend gibt es auch meist ein bisschen für Geld, ansonsten ist das Schall
und Rauch der Titel, das heißt, das ist ja gar kein Titel, das heißt gar nichts, das
ist einfach nur, dass irgendwie eine Senior davor geklatscht hat, du passt auf die Stelle
und dann bist es, aber die meisten suchen wie gesagt nach jemand, der Technik langjährig
Ahnung hat, aber auch ein bisschen, wie soll man das sagen, das vielleicht auch ein bisschen
besser kommunizieren kann, den du auf übergreifende Meetings schicken kannst, jemand der halt
auch gewisse, mit gewisser Überlegung an die Sache rangeht und nicht einfach nur sagt,
ja das machen wir so, das geht, also sprich das ganze vielleicht auch ein bisschen genauer
im Vorfeld zu analysieren, also sprich, wie könnte man das am besten umsetzen, vielleicht
auch mit dem Team, mit den zwei drei Verantwortlichen das bespricht, wie könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel
mal einen Upgrade auf neue Version machen oder sowas, jetzt nicht wirklich irgendwelche
Management Sachen, vielleicht kleine Sachen, aber hauptsächlich jemand der langjährig
Erfahrung hat und halt die Sachen gut, sagen wir mal gut einschätzen kann, der nicht quasi
bei jedem neuesten Hype sagt, oh geil, das stellen wir jetzt hin, direkt morgen in Brott
auf geht's, live, sondern der vielleicht dann auch mal sagt, okay, lass uns doch erstmal
ein ordentliches Konzept überlegen, wie man das betreiben kann auf Dauer, der kein Java
Skript developed hat, das klappt in der Fall nicht, erstmal neuestes Framework GitHub,
noch bevor es das über NPM kippt, direkt die Dateien runtergeladen, das ist auch ganz
wichtig, du musst nicht alles direkt können, ich würde auch nicht nur nach DevOps gucken,
guck nach Linux Engineer, System Engineer, Linux Administration, DevOps Engineer, das
kennt doch eh jeder wie er will, okay hier haben wir noch ein Desktop Bild, zeig mal
her, ich hab das nur angeklickt übrigens, weil ich es in der Vorschau schon gecheckt
habe, NeoFetch, Archlinux, beste, so ist das gut, by the way, ich glaube ich hab euch
das auch schon erzählt, aber ich benutze auch Archlinux, hier für alle die es interessiert
Leute, Archlinux, so heißt das, Archlinux, müsst ihr euch merken, NeoFetch, archlinux,
Archlinux benutzen nur die Profis, die Profis benutzen Archlinux und wichtig, ihr müsst
allen erzählen, dass ihr Archlinux verwendet, so wie ich das gerade mache, das ist essentiell
wenn ihr Archlinux verwendet, das ist so ein bisschen, es gibt ja diesen Witz mit Veganer,
woran merkst du, dass jemand Veganer ist, gar nicht, er wird es dir erzählen und so
ungefähr ist das bei Archlinux auch, woran merkst du, dass einer Archlinux verwendet,
gar nicht, er erzählst dir, aber nur echte, Manjaro zählt nicht, Manjaro Fake Arch, außerdem
ist man quasi fast schon Senior Engineer, wenn man Archlinux verwendet, so also was
haben wir denn hier, aha, aha, ich sehe schon, ich sehe schon, was hier angesagt ist, ok,
erstmal die Twitch-Channel stalken, was hier abgeht, na das geht ja noch, keine, keine,
Hot Pools, so, so, so, so, alles klar, Hot Pools, Pools, Hot Tubes, aha, aha, Gunray,
danke schön, egal, ich sage es, ich halte mich, ich halte mich zurück, ja, schicke
Terminal Hintergrund-Theme, ich vermute mal, dass die restlichen Sachen auch ganz gut drauf
angepasst sind, was für ein Prompt ist das, ist das, ist das, nee, das ist nicht Pure,
ist das Default Prompt von Oh My Cish, was ist denn das für ein Prompt, Pi-Theme, ok
also, ach so, es ist doch Oh My, Oh My Cish, Uploaded, Lul, wieso sind da 4 GPUs, da sind
nicht 4 GPUs, das Ding ist ich einfach nicht sicher, was es ist, es könnte eine Radio
in 6700, 6700 XT, 6750 XT und 6800M sein, Max sagt, na ja, weil du gerade geschrieben
hast, Buba, ihr wolltest sagen, wahrscheinlich ist die älter als die meisten bei euch im
Chat, ich glaube, Alinity ist älter als ich sogar, ne, wobei, ungefähr so alt wie ich,
ich glaube, ungefähr so alt wie ich, ja, ja, die ist, die ist fast genauso alt wie
ich, aber man muss, man muss natürlich sagen, also dafür hat sie sich gut gehalten, ja,
woher weißt du das so genau, man muss informiert sein, was auf Twitch so los ist, aber ansonsten
finde ich es ganz schick, hast du sonst noch irgendwas Customized, ja, deine Leiste oben,
da erkenne ich noch nicht mal, ob es jetzt wirklich i3 ist oder irgendwas ganz anderes,
ich würde mal vermuten, es ist i3, könnte aber auch was anderes sein, ne, Sway ist das,
oder?
Sway, ne, du hast doch vorhin sogar geschrieben, dass es Sway ist, aber ich wollte gerade sagen,
es hat was von i3, hat Vibes von i3, aber es sieht nicht am Ende i3 mäßig aus, da hast
du ja auch hier geschrieben Sway, jo, ganz schick, weiß ja nicht, was du sonst noch so
viele Terminals Teams und sowas am Start hast, aber ich denke, das kann man so lassen, kennst
du gute Schulungen zu Linux, kannst du mal ein Stream gucken, wir machen viel Linux Zeug,
Wobblos, bitteschön, Wobblos Stream, ja, da muss, da muss was gehen hier Leute, 40k,
da muss, die müssen da was draufhauen, die sind alle so am heulen, sie finden keine Leute
und dann wollen sie ihren Leuten nicht genug bezahlen, dass sie da bleiben, ja, weiß nicht,
wer das ist, ansonsten ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob es gute Linux Tutorials und Schulungen
gibt, das einzige, was ich mir zum Thema Linux angucke, ist irgendwie, wenn ich neue Tools
finde, ob es dazu schon ein Video gemacht hat, aber so Linux Basics sind bei mir halt
schon eine Weile ganz okay, deswegen gucke ich mir eigentlich nichts mehr an, geil, VRS
ist auch Sack, Alter, kann ich euch an der Stelle sagen, ich habe auch mal, wie ich klein
war, das müsste so 1998 rum gewesen sein, also war ich 12, habe ich einen Kurs gemacht
an der VRS und wisst ihr was, ich weiß dazu heute nicht mal wirklich viel, aber es ist
was, was ich eigentlich auch danach nie wieder machen wollte, Wischl Basic 6, wir haben damals
in Wischl Studio irgendwelches Zeug zusammengeklickt, aber wisst ihr worauf das rausgelaufen ist,
wir haben Half-Life mitgebracht auf gebrannten CDs damals und haben dann mit den ganzen Leuten
im Kurs Half-Life gespielt, kann ich mir daran erinnern, und die Lehrerin saß vorne und
hat quasi in der Nase gebohrt, wenn du so willst, wir haben da nichts gemacht, haben
alle Half-Life gespielt, also die hat nichts, im Prinzip haben die Eltern den Kurs bezahlt
und wir haben Half-Life gespielt in der Zeit, deswegen benutze ich jetzt die Sharp, nee hat
damit nichts zu tun, möglich wäre es aber, nee hat damit nichts zu tun, PowerShell Schulung,
PowerShell ist cool, PowerShell ist kacke als interaktive Shell zum täglich benutzen, finde
ich, aber für Automatisierung ist PowerShell ganz nice, allerdings nicht nice genug, dass
ich PowerShell unter Linux benutzen würde, hey Wischl Basic, das sah schon ein bisschen
so aus wie heute, es war ein bisschen weniger kontrastreich, nee das ist schon zu neu, ja
so in der Richtung sah das aus, ja ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, so sah das bestimmt
aus, nee nee nee nee nee nee, ja Wischl Studio 6, müssen wir mal suchen, ja so in der
Richtung sah das aus, ja genau, das kommt ganz gut hin, wobei ich glaube das war noch
primitiver, was zum Teufel ist Wischl J++, J++, ist das dieser Java-Abklatsch von Microsoft
wo sie dann von Sun verklagt wurden, Microsoft Discontinued Implementation of Java, oder
Java, das manch einer nennen mag, oh meine Augen, kann ich aufmachen, kenne wir uns nicht,
ja das habe ich dich letztens gefragt, ich weiß aber nicht mehr zu welchem Anlass ich
dich das gefragt habe, ach nee das war eine Antwort auf jemanden, was ich nicht sehe,
ok, weil das letzte Mal warst du auch hier und da habe ich auch gefragt, kennen wir uns
nicht und da sind wir aber zum Schluss gekommen, anscheinend nicht, ich weiß aber nicht mehr
warum ich auf die Idee gekommen bin, dass wir uns kennen könnten, das habe ich schon
wieder vergessen, ach nee du hast recht, ich habe mich vertan, du hast recht, ja der Fisch
war das den ich gefragt habe, ja Wischl Basic ist ja auch abartig, ich meine man darf nicht
vergessen Office Geschichten werden heute immer noch mit Wischl Basic gescriptet, Max
hast du Tipps wie man angenehm lernt, Tutorials durchklicken ist anstrengend, ja keine Tutorials
durchklicken um Tutorials durchzuklicken, sich ein cooles Projekt überlegen was man
gerne machen will, anfangen und an den Stellen wo man feststellt, dass man was lernen muss,
sich Tutorials dazu angucken beziehungsweise Webcasts dazu angucken, Tutorials durchlesen
oder eben wenn es gar so viele Kurs holen oder so, aber du brauchst ein Projekt wo du
Bock drauf hast und dann fängst du einfach an und lernst quasi während dem Projekt,
aber einfach Tutorials gucken bringt nichts, das hast du auch direkt danach wieder vergessen,
du musst, du musst, das schöne ist wenn du ein Projekt hast, hast du den Source Code
danach ja auch noch und kannst du jetzt abgucken wenn du das nächste Mal wieder was brauchst,
also du musst irgendwas selbst machen, du musst irgendwas selbst programmieren oder
ich weiß nicht was du genau machen willst, du musst selbst was bauen und während du
das baust dann feststellen, ah da weiß ich noch zu wenig drüber, ah da weiß ich jetzt
gar nicht wie es geht und dazu guckst du dir dann explizit was an und wenn du feststellst
du willst das mit einer Sprache oder einem Framework machen wo du gar keine Ahnung von
hast, dann musst du dir halt Sprachenbasics vorher angucken, mach ich gleich, mach ich
gleich, wobei ich nicht empfehlen würde Sprache und Framework zeitgleich zu lernen, also wie
benutzt du Windows und Linux gleichzeitig, das ist ganz einfach, ich zeig dir das, das
ist eine VM im Fullscreen auf einem zweiten Desktop, guck hier unten, ich hab also Hausbetriebssystem
ist Windows und auf dem ersten Desktop ist Windows, auf dem zweiten Desktop ist Forever
Workstation im, also auch Windows, aber Forever Workstation im Fullscreen und ich kann dann
mit der Tastaturkombination, Control, Windows-Taste, File-Taste links und File-Taste rechts hin
und her wechseln, das ist die Windows, das ist der Windows Shortcuts für Desktop Switchen,
guck ich kann es dir zeigen, wenn ich jetzt hier noch einen Desktop mache, dann kann
ich jetzt hier Switchen, erster Desktop, zweiter, dritter, dritter, zweiter, erster, erster,
zweiter, dritter. Leider gibt es keine Animation mehr zum Switchen, es gab unter Windows 10
noch eine Animation beim Desktop Switchen, aber da hat sich Microsoft gedacht, so bloated
Shit wie Animationen, das brauchen wir nicht, das gibt's nicht mehr unter Windows 11, das
heißt man weiß manchmal gar nicht, ob man geswitcht hat oder nicht, mit deiner Maus
eigentlich im Vorämmerfenster gefangen so, dass du erst mit Hortkey wieder raus, ja richtig,
ja so hab ich das, so hab ich das, ich weiß gar nicht, dass das anders geht, jaja guck,
achso, nee, vielleicht hab ich, nee ich hab auch so kein Lag, nee, warum läuft da Pearl
an, was ist denn das, achso, ASCII-Quarium, man kann sagen, bei mir läuft nie Pearl, ich
weiß, was ich gerade gesagt hab, das kann ich jetzt nicht zuordnen zu irgendwas was
ich gerade gesagt habe ok mein beileid
ja so also so funktioniert das bei mir mit mit desktops switchen
nice zu chat also ich werde jetzt offline gehen und wir werden dann morgen oder die tage auf
jeden fall die restlichen set servers machen jst lager schön für den sub nice hast du
gut gemacht logil halb ein fader ist bestimmt stolz auf dich aber ich gehe jetzt auf du bist
leider zu spät wir sehen uns macht's gut bis denn betke zu